here at the debenham leisure centre
my name's kathy guthrie and i'm the
chairman today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that all mobile phones are
turned off or set to silent
you will see some of us have our phones
and that's because we couldn't log into
the
internet at debenham leisure centre so
we're tethered
so that's why you see them here
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons at all
times
and that you wear a mask unless you are
speaking or if unable to do
so and that you use the hand sanitizers
and wipes provided
that you do not interrupt the other
speaker members are reminded they should
not have alternative communication lines
open
other team chats and that you if you're
contacted by a third party during an
application you should bring that to our
legal
advisors attention but if you are
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair of
the meeting
and we will be using e-voting on this
meeting on modern.gov
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to be recorded
by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
attendees are asked asked asked to note
that a break will be taken at an
appropriate point around 11 am
so may i now have introductions ian
duprey our legal advisor good morning
madam chairman
john paytman g the area planning manager
who will also be
presenting some of the cases robert
carmichael
our governance officer and sean bunbury
over the back there who is a case
officer
the ward members that were going to be
present unfortunately aren't
would you like to add to that please
robert thank you chair
um just to add to that point so the file
regulations for this building
are as follows that in the event of a
fire all people should
exit out of the main entrance or use one
of the other three fire exits around the
building
all exits must remain clear of chairs
tables and equipment
and if exiting the exiting via the chair
store or main entrance everybody should
meet in the green
bus stop which is out in the car park
uh and that is the designated fire
assembly point if exiting via the
kitchen
or the side lounge on the lobby on the
playing field everybody should walk all
the way around
the sports center so if you go out that
way you go all the way around
and then you'll go through the gate back
up to the bus stop should there be any
reason anyone cannot get to the green
bus stop people should gather on the
playing field
site at a safe distance if you hear the
alarm or see the red flashing lights
then please exit the building do not
delay or pack up your personal
belongings and also if there is any um
father and there's nobody else in here
at that point please alert the community
center as well
so um one other point just as a
clarification with the microphones
you don't have to turn them on they will
come on automatically
and also if you need the toilets they're
out there on
the right left my left hand side or your
right hand side thank you chair
thank you for that robert and there's
another thing if you do whisper or
whatever they will
if you whisper it to yourself it will
pick up the communication i believe
possibly yeah so
um just to be noted on that can i move
to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor gould
thank you to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members any to declare
no i don't see any declarations of
lobbying
um well i think we all received or most
of us might have received
um yes this for the
um item badwell ash
is that right everybody's got that thank
you if you could know that
declarations of pers oh sorry councillor
melon did you want to say something
yes sorry chair um i don't know if i
need to declare it but the babel
is in my county division thank you for
that
declarations of personal site visits
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 9th of june
are there any points of accuracy
councillor stringer
thank you chair uh page 8 and page 9 10
7 and 10
9 it didn't mention anywhere about the
debate about the concerns that the width
the width of the road conditioned in the
outline could actually be
met we had considerable debate on that
and it doesn't seem to be in there can
we look into that and amend that
accordingly
uh robert when we when you review the
minutes please
one second yeah i'll just have a
yeah if we want to if because that was
obviously part of the debate then i can
add something into that effect
um if we saw um to that are you happy to
leave
the officer to include appropriate
comment
thank you councillor thank you in that
case can i have a proposal please
okay councillor casten and the secondary
councillor norris thank you
[Music]
so um i believe you will now conduct an
electronic vote if you would please
thank you chair i would just get into
the
system so this is with um so i'll just
edit it so that it's with the amendment
as
because the string has said as well
[Music]
right
there we are so that's now in so the
vote is now open members if you go to
the plus sign in the top right hand
corner
of your agenda and then go on the uh
subsection on attendance voting that the
vote will show oh
it hasn't started my stream it will get
there in a moment
if you please bear with it um let's
start it will show in a light
blue color we'll just have to bear with
the system of foreign councillors
council humphreys as you're not logged
in can i take your vote verbally
thank you
[Music]
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is a unanimous vote
for
thank you thank you for that to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
none received chair and the schedule of
planning applications are as they are
presented
in the order
so we now start with item 7a dc2005917
land to the south of new street
stradberg
john papenge is going to introduce this
and i'll leave it over to you please
thank you
thank you
so this is land herself of new street uh
stradbroke
um so we'll start with
where are we i'm on the is this on the
screen
yep lovely thank you i'm on there as
well oh dear
so uh this is the west side of
stradbroke
um and there's never philadelphia to
show you where we roughly are
and we're going to skip through these
fairly quickly uh so strikework is a key
service center
it's new street is the main road through
the village leading on to church street
and queen street
at the central junction which is uh
adjacent to the all saints church
just in the middle there
the site itself so outline planning
permission
is granted with access to new street to
the north
the site is adjacent existing
development to the north
east and east is a community centre with
a pool and fitness center
and playing field essentially the the
green bit
next to the site show
[Music]
and just to go into the google street
google view of it
which is a little bit more up to date
this might be a little bit clearer
showing the brown field which is the
site
what part of it and the green to the
right hand side
of the screen is the playing field
[Music]
this is the official red line plan
but we are very much dealing with a
large open field
the constraints plan the site itself has
none of the normal planning constraints
but there are listed buildings opposite
and just to close in on those we have
timbers which is a grade two listed
building
uh directly opposite to the site um i
can't i don't know if you can see a
pointer but that's that one there
and the site also shows the current
settlement boundary in blue
but this is a reserve matters
application so we have moved on from the
principal
but we're going to go over all of that
in a moment
so block plan the proposed layout
essentially we have housing at the top
and a large public open space area to
the bottom
itself and this would be adjacent to the
existing playing area and community
center
just forgetting about the bit at the
bottom for the moment just helpful to
close in
on the proposed layout
and i think this is the point we need to
go through a few points of principle
first before we go any further so um
let's start with the outline planning
application
so the outline planning application was
granted
for erection of 60 up to 60 houses
with access only included so access to
new street
is dealt with by that outline permission
and this was granted in 2019 by
committee
so we are just are dealing with the
reserve matters today and that is the
appearance scale
layout of the buildings and the
landscaping of the site
some of the conditions under the outline
which is in your papers
do have a bearing on what is before us
or indeed what is not
needing to be before us today so i'm
going to go through a couple of those
because just
be clearer to do that at this stage
condition 1918
uh requires a footpath along the
road frontage uh in accordance with the
approved drawings
um can i point on this
that can you can you see a pointer or if
i'm moving that around
no hang on let me change the other way
around
all right can you see that pointer yep
lovely so the footpath
uh that's in the outline needing to be
part of the provision is actually that
one along the front there
at the top so that's already part of the
outline but it's
also part of the reserve matters because
it's part of this layout
so that's on the top there and that's
dealt with condition 22
required a sustainability and energy
strategy
to be agreed prior to any development
above slab
level so once they get building if they
get to slab level
they needed to have dealt with the
sustainability and energy strategy so
that is not before us today
i do appreciate members have sought
these
strategies and schemes prior to
commencement or part of reserve matters
on other cases
unfortunately that isn't the case here
so that it's slightly different in terms
of timing
just to bear in mind in debate later
condition 26 provides that the
development should be either
single or two-story development with no
rooms in the roof
and that is the scale that he's
presented for us at reserve matters so
we are in accordance with the uh outline
in that respect
there's no control on market housing mix
imposed at the outline nor were the type
of houses
so ultimately the reserve matters that
we do have in front of us has abided by
these outlying
conditions and is fully in compliance
with them
for the purposes of determining the
reserve matters
the outline also included a section 106
agreement
and in summary this secured 35
affordable housing and
the also included the open space that we
just saw at the bottom
the southern side of the site um
but the actual layout of the open space
is to be agreed with the district
council prior to the first
occupation of the of the dwellings
so there is still an agreement of what
goes on that
open space area and what it looks like
to come that is a separate matter
outside of the
matters that we are dealing with today
the agreement required the open space
area to be public open space
be maintained in a good condition until
it might be transferred to a nominated
party
prior to the occupation of the 75th
the nominated party
now that is listed in the 106 agreement
to be
a residential association a management
company
the parish council or a private limited
company
it will be for the developer or owner
the site to decide
ultimately who that nominated party is
um so that is not for our consideration
today either
i mentioned this because that has been a
debate
outside of these walls so the actual
specific specification of the open space
is to be agreed
with the district council outside of
this application
now this does include a local equipped
area of play um
and there has been conversations again
outside this room that
there's been an idea that maybe that
could be dropped an alternative
provision
be made instead unfortunately the 106
agreement doesn't allow
for the provision or agreement of the
local equity area play to be
dropped but there is a negotiation about
what the open space
can or cannot include so there are
ongoing negotiations that need to go
forward on that
um and i appreciate
it might not be what everybody wanted
but i'll come back to that in a moment
there has been a suggestion from the
parish council that there needs to be a
car park
involved unfortunately the open space
provision
and the 106 and the outline granted does
not include
provision for a car park area and that
has not come forward
accordingly so essentially what the 106
agreement is is simply for the open
space for public use and for agreement
on the specification of the open space
later and for the affordable housing
i will note genuinely that the this
agreement
in this case there's a lesson to be
learned here that it raises an
interesting point that the district
needs to agree
the specification of the open space but
it's not going to be the nominated party
in fact the district council is
specifically not listed as a potential
nominated party within the 106.
so i would suggest that officers in
future and
in this case when such agreement comes
forward in terms of what the
specification of the open space involves
should ensure they work with a developer
and whoever that nominated party may be
and i
suspect it's likely to be the parish
council but
or anybody else to ensure a smooth
transfer
of the land and ensure that the open
space specification
includes everything that everybody wants
and that may include things such as a
fitness trail
and connections to the existing playing
field which i understand
is the wishes of the parish council but
unfortunately that is a discussion for
another day or later on
back to the layout before us parking
is in accordance with the current
standards and slightly higher
in some places there are triple parking
for example especially around this area
here you may notice
um but that occurs when the parking is
in excess
of the standard requirements so for
example plot one which is
uh the top left here uh is a four
bedroom house it needs free spaces
according to the standards it's actually
got four spaces and a double garage
so they've got far more than actually
required
um so essentially if you took the
garages away you'd end up with
parking in parallel two parking spaces
as
we would accept
this is an allocated site uh under the
stradbrook
neighborhood plan under strat 17
and this has a bearing on the
consideration at outline stage being
access to new street the open space to
the southern half
of the site and other matters but it
also can include considerations
for the reserve matters as well in terms
of landscape buffer and design
so along the sides here we have as you
can see quite
a reasonable landscape buffer to soften
the edge of the development
in accordance with the requirements of
the neighbor plan
we also have the considerations of
strat2 which is the
neighborhood plans design policy
to consider as well and essentially that
looks to
have buildings in keeping with the
surrounding area
and in scale and so forth i'll come back
to that shortly um
the baby story oh yes one of the design
aspects of stride 2 is the setback
provision in respect of
emulating the setback position of local
housing so
we are set back from the new street just
as all the other houses are
along there we've not put the houses
aren't pushed forward uh
in order to conflict with the
neighborhood plan
um we then also have if i move on to the
next slide
the boundary and materials
plans and we also have a number of
landscape plans now i've
not put all of them here because there's
quite a few
to give us the as a scale that's just
not transferable to powerpoint
but we do have play services landscaping
experts who have reviewed all the plans
and support the proposal
drainage is an another element of the
neighborhood plan that is a strong
element
and this scheme has submitted its
drainage layout plan
and this is also approved which is good
very good for them
approved by a county's flood team
directly
phasing plan is part of the outlying
permission requirements
and they're essentially looking at
building in two phases
now there are a lot of elevations and
they are in your papers i'm not going to
go through them
blow by blow but um so just to look at
the street scenes
in terms of the range of housing we have
bungalows and two-story properties
and we have another one there
and we've got the various
designs
obviously with the listed building on
the frontage of the site
we have more traditional style
properties set
there some do have chimneys
and traditional details to reflect the
historic
environment along new street but as you
go into the site
we have a more modern approach and
chimneys are not
so apparent
but the site will be for it for the most
part its own place and its own
cul-de-sac
so only a few pictures here um because
it is an open field
um but this is the the new street this
is the entrance to the village
um those bungalows that you can see are
in the corner
where the site would be set against
the new entrance would be off this road
and the picture at the bottom there is
obviously looking the other way
essentially and out to the countryside
so you can see
how open a field this actually is at
this current time
so the bungalows that were in that
picture are effectively
this group here and obviously this is a
fairly open field
in terms of appearance scale and layout
of just the buildings
and landscaping of the site the proposal
is considered acceptable
the recommendation is approval we have
added a couple of conditions on
landscaping for the avoidance of doubt
and we are mindful of the open space
specification in the 106 that needs
approval
later so we want to ensure reflects
flexibility around this
we have included appropriately to
include a further
biodiversity benefit for our swift boxes
while strictly not a reserve matter
under the duty of all council decisions
to ensure the protection of wildlife
we consider this to be acceptable
addition and on that basis that's the
conclusion at this time
thank you for that john um just one
thing while you've got that up there
will mid-suffolk be adopting the
roadways within this
scheme do we know so the uh the
adoptable
road as i understand it would be this
one here coming through to the
the junction this at the turning head at
this point um
the rest i would probably think would be
the
uh private roads but i would have to
double check with the applicant
on that we can do that yeah thank you
for that
so members questions counselor stringer
yes thank you chair
uh two questions uh i was
constant reference to the section 106
what i couldn't see
was any reference to the section 106 in
the original outline planning permission
[Music]
i can't see the link so
so if there were asks from the section
106 i'm
asking where are they in the original
outline permission because i can't find
them i may have missed them
sorry the the outline playing permission
yes so the section 106 sits alongside of
the
the outline um normally we put a note on
the
uh decision editor to say that he's also
referred to the 106 but
that's an informative note and if it's
not on there i apologize for that
i think our legal can give us a hand
job's quite right i mean
the normal purpose of a section 106 is
to deal with matters that
can't easily or properly be dealt with
by planning conditions
and it would yes that there sometimes is
an informative note but
it it by it's normally well you always
signed before the planning permission is
granted
very often the permissions a day later
you will find and it
the planning obligations bind the land
and they will
standard wording says they will they
take effect when the permissions granted
and when development is commenced
although some if they have to they take
effect straight away
yes i understand that what i want to
know is how do i find out what the terms
of reference were for it
um what the ask was that's what i'm
asking oh i see so
well this was a committee resolution for
the outline and so the recommendation
was
as per the officer report for the
conditions that
were put into the 106 agreement and we
also have that section on obligations
and those obligations were for the open
space and for the
um affordable housing and it's that list
i was trying to find in these papers and
couldn't find them
that would be in the minutes the minutes
okay or the committee meeting the
authorized
resolve to grant the outline permission
i'm sure they can be found fairly easily
okay we'll look into that and see if we
can come up with that and one other
question these are for clarity
yes your other question please counselor
you did say that there were chimneys on
some of them
could you speak up sorry you mentioned
that some of the properties had chimneys
yes so the definition of a chimney is a
vertical channel or pipe which conducts
smoke or combustible gases
from a furnace so can you guaran
are you saying they are chimneys or are
they just a design detail that doesn't
fulfill that function
i do not know what the function of those
chimneys are because that is not
for me to deal with as a reserve matter
the reserve matter is the appearance
um and that's what i have before me
thank you thank you and um
sorry i did see some of that you'll have
to bear with me counselor custom was
next then counselor melon i'll catch up
with you all don't worry
council casting thank you madam chairman
um the previous slide that was up
would be um quite useful that one please
i haven't got anything yet which which
slide were you after um it's
with the it'll have the drainage on it
the layout
um the one before that i think
yeah perfect so um well so um
with this drainage um plan um we
it looks like we've got two attenuation
basins one in the bottom left hand
corner one in the
top right hand corner and a existing
ditch
running along the side um could you um
confirm whether the existing ditch will
take any water off the site
and also um which attenuations
basins fed from which area are they both
functioning attenuation
basis i understand them to be both
functioning attenuation basins and i
think they would eventually all both get
into the existing water system
that's the nature of it the attenuation
basins are there to slow down
the output of the water
coming from the side but you do have the
existing
ditch network which has been integrated
as essentially swales you know into the
site
so um i'm no expert unfortunately on the
specifics of the drainage
only that the county are quite fussy
about these things i will say
uh and ultimately though i have an
approval from them they have gone
through this from top to bottom and
they are satisfied with it okay thank
you thank you council casting councillor
mellon please
um yeah thank you chair um on page 25 of
our bundle we've got
a copy of policy strad 17
which i take is from the stradbrook
neighborhood plan
and it talks about this um this area
um being for development um and
proposals will be supported subject to
the following criteria and there's a
whole list of them
number or bullet point 10 there it says
if the development is served by a
sustainable long-term solution in
respect of electricity provision
in accordance with policy strad four now
we don't have stratfor
but um can you just tell me how that
has been addressed in the design
i can't tell you how it's been addressed
in this design before us
because the reserve matters before us is
again the appearance
of the of the buildings scale of the
buildings
and layout of the buildings the means to
power
the buildings would have been a part of
the outlying consent
and had to have been dealt with under
that um
so i i said in my presentation the
neighborhood plan
allocation has elements that would have
had to be dealt with at the outline
stage
and elements that would have can be
dealt with in terms of the reserve
matter stage
that is one of the elements that was
picked up in terms of the
outline stage there is a energy and
sustainability
strategy required as part of the
conditions of the outline but it's
required prior to
slab i think i said slab level um
condition 22 of the outline
which is in your papers for an energy
and sustainability strategy
now energy-wise i'm i'm getting means to
power is going to have to be part of
that
but ultimately that's still not until
slab level comes along which is when the
houses are just about to come out of the
ground
and until we get to that stage i can't
do anything until
they submit something for that condition
okay can i just
further clarify then will will that come
back to committee or that would just be
decided by an officer
um conditions normally are dealt with by
officer delegation
i think it's very difficult that we've
got an outline that's already got some
of these aspects from it and we're all
curious and
uh investigative um so thank you for
your question but
uh i hope that's uh answered your
queries
uh now then it was either councillor
norris and then councillor wall voice
we'll all get there councillor norris
thank you page 20
excuse me the comments from strategic
housing in their last paragraph
middle of the page they're going down
slightly
they state there does not appear to be a
layout plan that shows where the
affordable units are
located on the site we would like
clarification on this point
the affordable housing should be tenure
blind and located across the site so
they are integrated and not in one
cluster
i can't see any response to that
anywhere in the papers
and just before you go on if we wait is
there a second question
oh yeah well can we wait for the first
one yeah it's more of a comment the
second question
yeah okay it's just i was going to say i
think we've had those in quite a lot of
our committees
that um i think generally it depends on
how many
affordables there are as to where
they're positioned and um you know i
think we
we have to look at what okay how many
houses we've got and so on fine
so this this plan is actually quite
useful in that i
believe and i do apologize if i have got
this one because i'm
not the case officer um but the the is
it in color one
yeah it is um so the green um blue
uh colored dots are the affordable
housing at that end of the site
that's how i understand it to be if i'm
incorrect i
please let the agent here um to correct
me but i believe they are in that
cluster there
and your second comment is oh my second
is more of a comment post 28 well if
it's a comment can you keep it to the
debate rather than it's a question now
for clarity we want
well yeah okay it was more it depends
how you classify it
um if i just explain 7.1
is it a question or is it a comment we
need to know we're on well
it's a question then okay all right okay
so 7.1
paragraph at the top of the page the
penultimate
sentence reads the latter requirement is
not met
with 16 of the 25 1 and 2 bed
units comprising one beds but
and then there's no on qualification to
that
so what does that mean
what page were you on counsellor 28
28.
[Music]
sorry what paragraph so page 28 what
paragraph 38
7.1 the top of the page an ultimate
sentence
isn't finished oh yes
you're quite right so the the not the
last sentence but the one before
um but that'll be quite happy i
apologize
but for that error in the report i don't
know what that was supposed to say
but so we don't know what exactly that
is saying
effectively then
the lack of requirement is not there
obviously um
i do wonder if it's a case of just
taking the word but out of it and
putting a full stop
at the end yeah
essentially there is a a
conflict and it has been identified in
terms of
the housing mixed provision versus
what is proposed although my caveat to
that is
we didn't control market mix um
with regard to the outline so
it's this is where we are and
unfortunately that is the conflict that
we have
we have to look at thank you councillor
war boys please
thank you yeah uh thank you chairman uh
i i think my question's been answered
regarding the
energy strategy that it's partially
covered by the
initial planning applications so
on pages 56 and 57
from our environmental management
officer this quite detailed um
comments about an energy strategy so
overall are they included even though
we're not discussing them
today would they be included elsewhere
as it were
so um just to to clarify obviously that
we we still have the energy and
sustainability
uh strategy to come forward and and that
will involve energy
uh as a as a condition going back to the
requirements of the neighborhood plan
um strat four uh refer is so it refers
to utilities
um so that the section on strat 17 that
refers back to electricity
uh refers to strat four strap four i'm
saying right
side four is utilities provision and
um it's got three elements to it there's
surface water there's flower water as
well but then there's electricity
network
and for this it says this means
demonstrating that connection to the
network represents
a sustainable long-term solution to
serve the development without materially
increasing the likelihood of power
outages
to stradbroke village
in terms of the planning aspects of that
i can't deal with that in the reserve
matters before us
that would have needed to be dealt with
as part of the outline for the principle
of that number of houses to be placed
here in the first place
and whether or not adequate
infrastructure is available
and demonstrationably available to serve
that development
what we're dealing with is the reserve
matters of what the houses look like and
so on
so um i don't know the entire answer to
that
but i don't need to for the purposes of
this application
thank you for that any further questions
no
thank you for that we now move on to
public speakers and we have
odile walden for the parish council
representative if you'd like to come
here my colleague will give you your
three minutes thank you
[Music]
thank you um i haven't prepared any
speech because
this site is in the neighborhood plan
and the parish council supports it
the parish council was disappointed when
he saw that excuse me section 106
agreement because it doesn't comply
with the requirements of the
neighborhood plan um the
open space was designed to be an
extension of the playing field
therefore a leap in the middle of it
wouldn't really be beneficial
um but i've been speaking with mr
papengia and i think we've come to an
arrangement of how we can progress that
in answer to strad four there are areas
of stradbroke
that if they were connected to the um
the network doesn't have the capacity
this is not one of the sites when we did
our selection of sites we specifically
picked this one because it is at the end
of the village
that has capacity the the policy was put
in
to ensure if any other developments came
forward that we could enforce
the capacity issue we did think long and
hard about our neighborhood plan
um we've put in a lot of housing we are
very disappointed that
it's taken two years to actually get to
any development and i know that's
unusual for parish council to complain
but um we we did produce this plan to
make the village sustainable to make the
primary school viable to maintain the
viability of the high school
to make the businesses successful so we
we are not
anti-development we are just very
disappointed that the section 106 didn't
reflect the community benefit
that this site should have brought
forward every site that was put into our
plan we chose
5 out of 14 all of them were selected
because of the community benefit they
brought
otherwise we would have selected one of
the other nine so
that's the only comment i have to make
about this but that's not for the
matters before you as john would say
and i have pinched that and use it in my
parish council meeting so thank you john
but i'm here to answer any questions i
know the neighbourhood plan inside out i
helped
write it i helped design it so um i'm
happy to answer any questions that you
have
thank you very much indeed for that
members questions
at all oh
i should just say the parking sorry the
the
open space we thought would have a car
park attached to it
and we were asked to comment on that in
march or april this year by master who
was the planning officer
marcel was concerned if the car park
wasn't there then people visiting the
pla
the open space may use the development
for parking
but as we don't know the layout of the
open space we agreed with the developer
that we
would take a payment in lieu of the car
park and put the car park
where it needed to be when it needed to
be i now understand that that's not an
option
um and i wish we'd been told that
when the officer was going to put the
car park in the open space for this
meeting but we weren't so i suppose what
we're saying is we hope the developer
holds true to his words and gives us
some money
to help us make the open space something
the village can use
i think your latter comments really are
something outside our meeting today but
i appreciate you being able to say them
and let us hear them so thank you very
much for that and i'm sure the community
will be appreciative
thank you so any further questions at
all thank you very much indeed
thank you and thank you for being so
positive
thank you
[Music]
we don't have an objector or a supporter
but
we do have the agent um and that is
sam sinclair if you would like to come
along
and make a presentation please and you
two will have three minutes thank you
very much
[Music]
good morning chair and members of the
committee my name is sam sinclair
technical manager at level east anglia
and i'm happy to answer any specific
questions on the details of the
application after this
we've been working with the planning
authority um over the duration of the
reserve matters application to design
the scheme
in accordance with the constraints and
the current policy requirements
the the committee report that's been
delivered um
for your consideration and i'd like to
obviously support that
um with the conclusions in it and just
add a couple of additional points
um i'm pleased to bring forward the
scheme that includes a 35
affordable policy compliant scheme which
is above
the level of the local emerging policy
or joint local plan the majority of our
current schemes are facing challenges
um in the environment where costs are
increasing
and values not necessarily so yet um
which does
present viability issues and please in
this instance that's not the case
we have addressed the issues of surface
water through design
and spent in excess of thirty thousand
pounds on ground investigation surveys
and consultant fees to ensure that we do
have a
compliance scheme which has been
approved by the lead local flood
authority
uh we're familiar with the ground
investigations with with the ground
conditions and the site constraints
and all the units will be served via air
source heat pumps
fabric enhancement has been included an
orient and orientation has been
optimized wherever possible
we are looking to include electric
vehicle charging infrastructure
and for this as we have as we are doing
for other developments
we have worked closely with the parish
council who are keen to see the scheme
excuse me come forward performing part
of their local plan
um and in this case our other sites in
mid-suffolk
we've progressed with the development
shortly after the planning approval
if approved today we are planning to
proceed without delay and
subject to detailed design work and
approval of the infrastructure design
we're looking to
make a start later in the year so we're
keen for the project to move forward
and hopefully be able to support the
officer's recommendation
but happy to take any questions thank
you for that
as you were reading i was writing out
one of my when do you hope to put
the seed should we should we uh prove
this but uh you clearly
gave us uh the information there uh
councillor humphreys a question i'm sure
thank you just two questions if i may
um first question is on the boundary the
landscaping
seems a little bit sparse doesn't
certain papers but looking at the
diagrams and the layout it looks pretty
sparse on the southern boundary which
goes out to the countryside is that just
illustrative
or is there a plan to plant more trees
or hedgerows to break that boundary down
a bit a little bit it's a little bit
harsh
i'm not sure all the actual the full
landscape plans were in the presentation
my apologies i did the problem with the
landscaping plans is they
are quite detailed and as soon as you
transfer them onto a powerpoint it
becomes this sort of busy mess
but there is there is a lot more than
than meets the eye this is very much
um open board brush in respect to what
is shown on here um unfortunately the
best plan i've got
the other thing of course is that there
is landscaping in terms of the southern
part
but the open space element then drops
below that so i'll just go back one more
so the specification of the open space
area hasn't been agreed entirely because
it's part of the 106
councillor stringer would you ask your
question yes thank you thank you chair
uh yeah given we've got this curious
condition that
uh for energy conservation and uh
ecological ways of design will kick in
at
slab level given the orientation of a
slab
is actually the biggest predeterminator
of the energy use of a building
that presents a challenge uh but looking
at the overall plan
out of the 40 50 blocks of roofs here
there are only seven that don't present
the best roof form for putting pv panels
on or passive solar gain
is there a reason however that three of
those blocks out of the seven
are the affordable housing blocks could
it not have been designed
that the affordable houses could have
had
the ability to have pv panels in the
future
they do because they're the south facing
units the affordable housing
run across the boundary at the bottom
they're also the ones at the right hand
side as well
yes and three of those blocks their
roofs don't face south
and there are three of the seven only
blocks on that site that don't face
south
what i'm asking is could there not have
been a way to design that where the
all of the affordable houses or a
smaller proportion of the affordable
houses roofs
didn't face south
given that there's a greater likelihood
that those in affordable housing may
fall into
fuel poverty it's a it's a
it's a possibility but it doesn't
it's not totally precluded if they're
not south facing they can't have
pv panels it just makes them less
efficient marginally
can we not have a debate you've had the
answer to your question thank you
um now who was next councillor custon
thank you
thank you very much um yes could i ask
why um the reason for the two
attenuation um
basins and also whether they will hold
water
for long periods of time this is from a
safety point of view
um will they contain water for periods
of time
and are the measures to um stop children
from
getting in them they're very close to
their houses yeah firstly that they will
for a period of time um but they're
designed they are designed to
to drain they fall to the to the parcel
in the north
northeast and then an outfall into the
existing through those houses into the
existing system and there is protective
measures around them we usually
have a knee rail or a guard rail around
them
thank you thank you very much councilman
helen
uh yeah thank you chair um you mentioned
earlier about um
the orientation of the houses uh
being you know fortuitous or or or
designed in
um have your your design
has that taken account of um
or designed in uh passive solar gain
uh by you know the use of appropriate
overhangs and that sort of thing
or is it simply south facing glass which
obviously has a risk of overheating
it will do in the future uh that is
still is the next step in the design
process
going from here thank you
any further questions thank you very
much indeed
i'd like to return to your seat um
we now have um rob
who's going to read the ward members
presentation thank you
thank you chair so this is from council
judy flatman
who can't be here this morning so
apologies for not being with you today i
have previous council commitment with
the health and
health scrutiny committee the suffolk
county council
firstly i'd like to say we were all very
happy with this development
unfortunately there seems to have been a
slight error along the way
i'm very disappointed that the
landowners would wish was not
transferred
to the section 106 agreement and also
that it does not reflect
the neighborhood plan i'm sure the
committee will listen with interest and
ask what can be salvaged
for a community that embraces
development and wants to provide housing
for all needs
brad bro cat parish clerk odell bladden
will be able to answer any questions
cass judy flatman
i think that was written before her
understanding of the
section 106 arrangements and i'm sure
she's been
in contact with the parish council and
the parish council clearly gave
their views um so thank you to that
and of course councillor flatman isn't
here to pass further comment
so we thank her for the input there so
we now open up for debate
madam chairman sorry if yes please any
help i've
i've found the minutes of the meeting of
the of the b committee on in april 2019
and i'd if i was mindful councillor
stringer had asked a question about that
yes
that would be helpful to just um
embellish the response that
we need if you would just give us a
crazy i'm trying to read my screen
without
causing problems for the i.t but can you
move your desk back a bit
is it all right if i just yeah it's
because we've got no one there
um just proceed if you would that would
be so kind thank you
i'm just opening it i put them in
folder so they're easily accessible it's
now my laptop is having to open it again
which is
causing a slight problem um so this was
mid-south development control b
committee 24th of april 2019
and the minutes record for this item
it's in the middle of quite a long
meeting um
minute117
it stated
um there's a comment that two
councillors
um who were not cur members current
members of this committee
asked the recommendation to include the
limit to two-story properties not
2.5 no rooms in the roof space garages
energy efficiency measures to be agreed
additional notes on national space
standards advanced landscaping on site
should be planted in advance
etc then the resolution itself
refers to subjects the prior agreements
of a section 106 obligation
on appropriate terms the satisfaction of
the acting chief planning officer to
secure
on-site delivery of 35 affordable homes
of a mix and tenure as advised by the
strategic housing officers
on-site provision of public open space
play equipment including management of
the space to be agreed and requirement
for
public access and the financial
contribution for
bus stops etc i won't read the whole of
that
and then the rest goes on about
conditions which wasn't the point of
concern so
i i'm a bit always a bit we need to be
careful we're in unusual times i don't
would it help if i
show you my screen madam chairman he
emailed this to councillor stringer if
he wants to look at it in the meetings
i don't think my counselor stringer
should be the only one that has it
i'm i'm perfectly happy with what's been
read out and i just wanted to understand
why i can't follow it in here that would
have been really helpful to know
what was asked by the committee for that
section 106 to include
thank you so we're we've had the
response thank you very much councillor
stringer
and thank you ian right okay so we'll
open up to debate and as we're now in
live session where we can see one
another who would like to go first
please
oh i like the alphabetical one then you
have to
counselor thank you and
usually first alphabetically anyway so
yeah
um yeah i like this design this um
section 106 i understand that this is
not
something that we're looking at today
but um it is a shame
that we're in that position with it the
um
but i've i hope that it's all um sorted
out to everyone some
satisfaction the um the parish council
have
been very forward thinking they've got a
good neighborhood plan in place
i think this um falls into that quite
nicely
it's um it's a sensible location the
access well the access has already been
agreed and
outlined but the out access seems um
sensible and these seem like i'm good
quality um
houses with air source pumps so um i
like
i like the design and layout and um
i'm yeah i'm i like what i see
thank you councillor casten who's going
to be next please
anyone else want to debate or are we all
going to go straight to council stringer
yeah
one other little point that's why i want
to dig around the section 106 to see
what the
terms were have we actually nailed down
and signed
who is going to do the affordable
housing and what that tenure
is because there is a request and it's
in the neighborhood plan
that the allocations policy should be
someone with a local connection
first and i have to say quite a huge fan
of that
because that helps build communities and
and strong communities and
also really invigorates people's faith
in affordable housing because if
communities feel it's just going to be
those with the most need across a region
that will end up in these houses
it makes sometimes more resistance to
that housing whereas if they know that
their local need will be met first
that's a very very good thing in
practice before john replies can i just
ask the legal officer whether we can tie
anybody down to such a
thing whether it's in the neighborhood i
did i did read the section 106 last
night i i
need to remind myself now of anything
very precise but
um it obviously the provisions of the
106
um the bind the land um
but yes i mean i think john payton g has
explained that if
we we're limited at this stage to
um the reserve matters which are um as
as you as members of this committee will
well know of layout
access has already been dealt with
layout scale appearance landscaping
um if not already dealt with an outline
stage
um but if you if you want me to advise
on what the 106 says precisely about
local connection
i will just need to look it up on i can
do that fairly quickly
would that be helpful i mean given how
vague this is and i can't believe it's
ended up
with with a minute like that in the
first i can't change that can we not
just put an informative note there if
that hasn't been solved
i've written that we could put an
information we would we would actually
support
that local housing allocation first
thank you chair
i i think that would be mostly apart
from that i have you know a few niggles
with with the plan but it's probably in
that bucket that's normally
not bad enough to refuse so with that i
will
be brief thank you chair thank you for
that councillor humphreys
i'm chair thank you um just looking at
reserve matters and what we're actually
here to vote on
again i agree with you this is a fairly
good plan
it's within the neighborhood plan as
well it seems there's really good
coordination and communication between
the parish
and also mid-suffolk district council
which is refreshing
and i see no reason to refuse what we
see in front of us
thank you thank you for that anyone else
wish to speak councillor norris
i thank you madam chairman uh like
councillor humphreys um
i can't see any reason really to refuse
this application
i would just comment again on the
affordable housing i think it might have
been better if they had been more
integrated
into the layout but uh overall um i will
be supporting this application
thank you thank you councillor norris
and
councillor boys thank you uh yeah it
just doesn't follow
i think it is a good scheme uh
it's good to see how the neighborhood
plan has been an important part of
bringing
this scheme forward um i just i'm a
little bit uncomfortable
at the fact that the energy strategy has
been sort of excluded at this stage
uh i think it does have a lot of
implications for
appearance and layout
and the materials that would be used to
minimize the environmental
impact so i don't
quite accept how they can be separated i
realize they have been separated but
i don't think it's a good um precedent
to set perhaps
that's my concern thank you for that
listen
just very quickly on that point um
things have moved on but the troubled
outlines as they were
two years ago or more um and so our
expectation for that condition in the
even in the last year
has been that we have now started to
recommend to members
that is co-current would reserve matters
as opposed to set back so late
um it's a learning lesson that but
unfortunately we've still
got other conditions that were written
in a different format
several years ago that are still
relevant now and this unfortunately is
one of those
uh so i do take your point in terms of
the timing
and i don't disagree but ultimately
i have to deal with what's presented in
the context of how it's presented
um in future we are trying very much to
ensure that those
similar policies so similar conditions
are concurrent
would reserve matters for the very
reason as you pointed out
thank you for that thank you thank you
council mellon do you want to say
anything or not
no thank you uh right then we've
all had um a say i would just comment
that
i really would rather like to say i'm
very pleased with what i
see and and definitely not say i can't
see a reason for refusing it i think we
should be positive about these
planning applications and say i like
what we see and um
thank you to the parish council and to
everybody and to the debate from
everybody
and i too will be supporting this so i
think we've had sufficient
uh debate yes councillor casten i was
just going to say i need a
propose thank you very much madam
chairman
i will say that in debate the um we
talked about where the um
affordable housing is and i think on
this plan
it's in an absolute prime position on
this site
i think it's a really good place i hate
to see it tucked in a corner in a
in you know tucked away and but it's not
on this one it's
um it's right by the um open space which
which is really good to see but yes i'd
like to one propose
that this be approved thank you do i
have a second up please councillor
mellon
yes happy to second chat thank you very
much indeed
and robert if you'd like to make the
vote available for us thank you chair
um just to check is that to include the
additional
informative note that was discussed oh
definitely a informative note
uh councillor casten yes informative
note that we would support local
um contractors yes yes
workforce workforce i think yes thank
you for being with me two moments joe
i'll just add that into the vote thank
you very much
not quite
can we just clarify the wording of that
informative because i
i wasn't sure if we quite captured what
councillor stringer was
uh well robert will give us this i
haven't written down as
the informative note to support local
excuse me to support local housing
allocation
first as per the neighborhood plan is
that
what was i thought it was local
workforce actually
no local needs oh local needs okay yes
sorry that's workforce and those that
live there
you did use that word you did
i would just add that in
so i've added in to readers informative
note to support local housing
allocation first as per the
neighbourhood plan is that acceptable
um yeah and also
well i should just ask the the the
person who wanted the proposal
councillor stringer is that
that's right okay thank you so chair i
will now open up the vote
again i would ask members to bear with
as we are
running on a lower connection today
so it should be starting momentarily if
members could go to the plus sign in the
top right hand corner of their agenda
and go on the subsection on voting slash
attendance and there the
vote will be shown in a light blue color
counselor
councillor humphreys can i take your
vote please poor thank you
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is unanimous
in favor of the proposal thank you very
much indeed everyone
thank you um i think actually it's a
good time to take a quick
uh 10 minute break please because we
then start the next
application thank you very much
everybody for attending thank you
hello and everybody welcome back uh we
now move on to the
next application dc 20 04785
north of the broadway badwell ash and
the case officer sean bunbury will
introduce the application if you would
please thank you
thank you chair the planning application
before us is a reserved matters
application following the approval
of an outline application in 18 a 2018
reference dc slash 18-0257
the current application is the reserve
matters dealing with appearance
landscaping layout and scale
and has also included details of two
conditions condition number nine
relating to surface water drainage and
condition 15
which has also covered landscaping
and just as a point of reference the
outline mission was granted
at a time when we didn't have a
five-year housing land supply
so the application site shown hatched
in pink and edged in orange is
located to the north of the village of
badwell ash
itself this road here is called the
broadway
hence the application site is described
as north of the broadway
and this is the street which leads north
to walsh from the willows
[Music]
on this aerial photograph here you can
see
the start of some housing development
which is either just started under
construction in the case of this site
here where the access has been
put in and the dwellings here are
mostly nearing completion and some are
actually occupied
and i have got plans later just to show
as an indication of how that development
relates to the application site before
us
so a slightly wider context and the
application before us today includes
a link through this other associated
not associated the adjacent residential
development
down to back lane and into the center of
badwell ash where there is the pub and
the village shop and the post office etc
so there is that footpath link from the
site
through and down to the center of the
village
this purely shows the red line
boundaries of the application site
and the constraints map show that it's
outside the flood zone area
um it's outside the settlement boundary
which is why i mentioned
the um the status of the five-year
housing land supply when the outline was
granted but the site is now allocated
in the draft joint local plan and as you
can see there aren't any nearby listed
buildings
the nearest is is quite a distance away
in the street
so this shows the development opposite
the application site just to give you an
idea
of the um the pattern of the development
that is um approved or underway
opposite the application site on land to
the south
of broadway
so this is the site layout of the
development
you can see the access is a single
access point
which was actually approved as part of
the outline application
so the access and the visibility
displays were approved at the outline
stage
so there's a main access road in
which then spurs off to paved roadways
and in this part here there's a private
drive
the attenuation basin is located to the
west of the site
on the lowest um part
of the in terms of the topography of the
site
as you come in there's then a paved
footpath which leads
around the edge of the site
in through the development there's
paving footpaths either side of this
main access road
paving across a footpath across the open
space
and also then there's an informal
footway
which leads across the road frontage and
then
down with the links to the
center of the village
the dwellings are mainly two-story
this is possibly a bit difficult to see
but the brown shading
is the two-story element the orange
is one and a half stories which provides
some linkage in some of the designs
and sort of wing if you like to some of
these larger properties at one and a
half stories
and at the back of the site we have a
group of single-story bungalows
in terms of the affordable housing it's
these plots here and up the side
here so again front in the open space as
in the previous scheme that we've
considered this morning these two houses
here
are open market housing and then the
affordables continue along in terms of
some single-story properties including
two one-bedroom
bungalows and then it leads on into the
remainder of
development
[Music]
also on the site layout plan
you can see that there is a four meter
wide landscape buffer to the north
and the east of the site
there is new roadside planting along
the southern boundary although there is
some retention of hedging
outside of the visibility splay but
otherwise it is new planting
along the road frontage and there's a
retention of some of the
existing trees along this western
boundary as well as new
landscaping provision
so the 12 affordable units that i've
just highlighted
in this area here nine of those
are for affordable rent and three are
shared ownership
which is all in accordance with the um
the section 106 agreement and the
provision that was required and
identified
by the housing department and
that has a mix of one two and three
bedroom
properties
parking spaces are generally provided on
plot
which includes garages there's a parking
court
here and a bit of communal parking
in this area here and garden sheds are
provided
for the dwellings which don't have
garages themselves
and there are nine visitor parking
spaces
around the layout which meets the
highways standards
uh some of the slides i've got here go
into more detail than we really need
but this just shows the external works
with the different surfaces to the roads
uh the provision of fences to the back
gardens
and walls in some
spaces where back gardens meet the
public
domain
this colorful plan just indicates the
range of materials that we've got on the
plots
which is a range of brickwork or render
or some boarding
to the dwellings there's plinths and
and coins and brickwork detail and the
roofs are either red or black pantiles
or slate
so in a bit more detail um the
landscape uh proposals um again
it's it's too small for us to see in
detail
um but you can see that landscape buffer
um
around the uh the field edges of the
site
and there is a hierarchy of planting
the boundary the field boundaries and
then there's native planting
proposed in that sort of location with
trees such as oak field maple
silver birch and hornbeam and then along
the frontage
um and the road side where you've got
what's called avenue or street trees
those are smaller so you've got things
like small leaved lime gray alder and
hazel
and then within the gardens you've got
more appropriate
smaller trees such as cherries etc and
ornamental trees
and this plan again also shows the
position of the sheds
in the gardens
the street scenes show the topography of
the site this is the main
road frontage onto the broadway so you
can see that the site does slope
down and then continues to where the
attenuation
basin is proposed
the next couple of slides go into more
detail of the planting schedule
but suffice it to say that that has been
looked at and is considered
acceptable in detail
and again the drainage strategy there
has been a lot of negotiation
uh between the applicant and our floods
authority
to sort out all the drainage the surface
water disposal etc
as well as the landscaping and
ecological
matters on the site so um
that there has been quite a degree of
collaboration on this scheme
i'll just go through some of the
elevations now
which show the range of designs
and materials that are proposed
and there are various details that are
incorporated such as the brick
corbelling
and the eaves details there's a range of
porches
and there's also arches and details over
the fenestration
so i'll just flick through these because
it it it does contain
the whole range of the elevations
so you can see there's also apart from
the brickwork there are some elements of
rendered features with
the uh sort of drip molding and the
pentas boards and the
barge boards so they've uh and the
proportions of the gables so they've
picked up various elements
of the vernacular um on the overall
development
and then the next lot of slides really
are the um
the the associated floor plans
so i'll just flick through these and you
can see the range of
one two and three bedroom and four
bedroom properties when we get to the
market housing
as well
a single garaging and double garaging
proposed
which meets the standards for parking
provision
and one of the garages proposed to be
given over is the sales
center to start off with and we have
details of
the um the the walls and garden fences
etc
then a few photographs just to introduce
the the site to you so this is the road
up towards walsh from the willows and
this is the
junction up to the broadway so the
application site
lies here as you can see it's really
just an
open field with some roadside vegetation
and at the back of the site
there are some newly planted trees and
more established trees that run along
behind the site
this is looking from the street across
the application site so this field here
is the application site
and the roofs here are of those
dwellings that are under construction
south of the broadway
the access point here is um
recently put in to serve the
uh the corner plot south of the broadway
and then
here you can see the houses that have
recently been completed
and the application site is behind this
hedge
again dwellings opposite the site just
showing you the character
of those including two story and single
story
and looking this side here
is the application site
and just to reinforce that it's it's
basically an open field
at the moment with some roadside hedging
and trees
and that's looking down to where the
attenuation basin is proposed
and that white van is on the road to
walsh willows
so as i say the application has involved
quite a lot of discussion
and agreement has been reached on all
the various
details the recommendation
is to approve the reserve matters
there are a few um there are a number of
outstanding matters relating to the
outline application and the conditions
which still need
to be met um but we have also suggested
that a construction ecological
management plan and biodiversity
enhancement strategy should be
incorporated
as well as provision of the fire
hydrants as requested
now that the layout has been established
so recommendation is in your papers to
approve
thank you chair thank you for that um
just before i ask
members for questions can you just put
up that photograph
where you show the entrance in this
house is opposite with the tree and
there's a tree on the entrance
um that one what's happening to that
tree and is it a
what sort of tree i'm afraid that is in
the visibility display
does that could have come out is that
where that would come out i'm afraid
that's in the visibility display
the visible the access is is um roughly
in this location here
but there is new tree planting shown
behind some of the hedge in this
frontage of the site can be retained
because it's outside the visibilities
and what's the entrance to the right
then what's that
um that's just an existing field
entrance but that will be
um blocked off locked off and in court
and then more
planting yeah right okay thank you for
that members would you like
questions at all councillor humphreys
then councillor castin
and chair thank you um it's just a
question referenced the
bad world ash parish council
who said that they would be withdrawing
withholding approval until the matters
that are listed on page one two one have
been resolved
can confirm that the conditions within
the recommendation
have satisfied their issues there's a
condition proposed for the
fire hydrants well building regulations
would be covered by the building
regulations that relates to access so we
haven't really got
um powers to include that anyway thank
you
and councillor casten thank you
uh
i'm not quite sure but i thought some of
the trenching had been done
um but the archaeological conditions
will be ongoing anyway so even if they
haven't done them now they will still
have to do them
at the appropriate time and and provide
the written
reports whether anything's been done at
this stage i'm not quite sure
perhaps we can ask the agent if you'd
like to ask that question later
um counselor melon thank you yeah thank
you chair
um i could just say i drove past a
couple of weeks ago and there were
diggers working in
in that field so i assumed something was
going on um
just going through the papers and i came
up with uh five or six
little sort of um loose ends which i
just wanted to
run through and i think are they just
questions because we need to sort of
it's a clarification i suppose yeah if
that's okay yep
um so on page 107 um
it talks about uh the officer has
requested
a sustainability and energy strategy
um now page 108 the public realm
uh seeking a local management solution
for the future management of open spaces
um page 108 again landscape place
services
um querying the height of three boundary
walls
um and then on page 111 the mid-south
disability forum um requested at least
one of the dwellings should be built
to wheelchair standard part m4 brackets
three
two the other things i had have been
dealt with the construction ecological
management plan and the bio
diversity enhancement strategy so
welcome those but just those other four
little
loose ends that one if they could be
tied up or whether we could do something
with conditions
um well i can see clarification in terms
of the exact details of the boundary
walls which was um mentioned
the landscaping response did go into
a lot of detail um and
not all of it sort of originally it came
in at a later stage but i can check the
heights
of the boundary walls but i assume that
where they are on to back gardens they
will be the 1.8 metre
high that would be the standard
the sustainability um there wasn't a
condition
on the outline um again this is a little
bit like the previous
application um and
it it doesn't really form part of the
layout and the appearance of the
dwelling so we
we we didn't really feel we had the
capacity to put
a sustainability condition on at this
stage
um although the agent has indicated
although it's not shown on the drawings
he has indicated that
they'll be looking at air source heat
pumps
[Music]
or all the dwellings
and standards sort of exceeding the
um the building rigs um
but we it's possible that we could put a
condition on if
if members felt so in terms of the um
air source heat pumps
for sort of technical data um
arising from from the layout but we
could perhaps explore
that at a little later stage um
building rigs and wheelchair access um
that's not really covered by planning
but that would be covered by
um by the building regs and i think
there are some properties that are
wheelchair accessible uh does that
cover all the points i think we can ask
the agent for
sort of more clarify clarity on that
again if that's okay with you councillor
mellon
and and thank you for the explanations
of what we can and can't do today thank
you
councillor stringer yeah two things one
thing could you just point out again
where the affordable housing units are
because i was either half asleep or
didn't quite um
it's it's these units one two three on
the road frontage
and then the ones that go up here um
and up into this corner and then along
here and then
there's two one-bedroom bungalows
thank you that's helpful though those
properties are not the affordable so it
kind of wraps around and
that's helpful that's very helpful thank
you the other question is
is bear in mind we can put a landscape
condition on
we will it it's very difficult to plant
a a tree that's already
mature is there absolutely no way we can
preserve that existing quite
substantial tree that's on that site uh
john if you would just answer that for
us please because i did ask this at um
i do hate to be the bearer of bad news
but um ultimately the
access was agreed as part of the outline
planning permission already that
included an access
plan and that included all the
visibility displays with it
and essentially that tree is gone in
terms of that plan or the agreed
outline um you wouldn't
would the tree is in the way of the
access point
that has been approved i don't think we
can make any adjustments around that
and ian is nodding in in agreement with
john's comment but i did inquire of that
myself
cancer stringer so we have tried
but but have you tried it now i just
just want to come back on that into i i
get exactly what you're saying
uh but well hang on we're not debating
you've asked the question you've got the
answer
so if you'd like to bring that up in
debate and counselor melon it's only a
question it's not debate at this point
thank you
sorry uh it's something i forgot to ask
um
i sort of understand the um pedestrian
connectivity
across the broadway into the
um the easternmost development
which is i think it's called wilding
close and that leads into the centre of
the village
but there's obviously another crossing
into the the western
development which he said is just being
begun does that connect through into the
village itself as well
i think that one's a cul-de-sac okay
thank you thank you any further
questions please clarity
no all right
so we don't have a representative from
the parish an objector
or a supporter so i'll now ask the
applicant which is chris smith if you'd
like to come forward
and if you give your presentation and
then
members may have the questions that you
might have heard already but we can ask
you those as well
but your presentation if you would in
your three minutes please
thank you
thank you madam chairman members my
name's chris smith
i'm development planner for hopkins and
moore uh
as you've heard from the case officer
following the previous grant of outline
planning commission for the residential
development of this site
we've developed and refined the detail
proposals now before you
in consultation with your officers and
the various statutory council teams
to produce the development which we feel
will be very much in keeping with the
character and appearance
of the village of badwell ash as you
will note from the committee report as
you've heard from your officer
all the statutory consultants are now
content that we have simply addressed
all the required technical and
environmental aspects of the proposals
we're confident that the proposals will
provide an attractive new development
in a sustainable location delivering 12
much-needed new affordable homes
together with all the requested
contributions towards the essential
infrastructure
via the seal and section 106 procedures
in summary therefore
we very much hope that you can concur
with your office's recommendation
that proposals represent sustainable
development and that you're able to
support
your approval of reserve matters here
thank you and as you've indicated i'm
happy to answer any questions members
may have
thank you very much for that um can i
just say i will invite councillor mellon
but there are two questions that aren't
relevant to
today's meeting which is um the
sustainability or the wheelchair issue
which is building register would you
like to ask the questions
of the applicant you had a couple there
that weren't quite answered wasn't there
yeah thank you chair um so uh the
mid-suffolk disability forum have
requested that at least one of the
dwellings
and i assume that meaning the single
story dwellings should be built to
wheelchair standard part m4 brackets
three
are you willing to commit to that think
that was one of the ones that we weren't
going to
inquire of today it's not in planning
it's not within our remit today
am i correct yeah that's right sorry
that's not one that we can ask today and
and also the sustainability that's not
in there right
because you had a ian can you correct me
i think unless it relates to one of the
reserve matters criteria of scale
appearance layout i
and i think john that would be your
mindset as well
the um okay so we're looking at reserve
matters
and ultimately that's appearance and
layout we do have before us also
all of the floor plans of the proposed
properties
um what if the
uh to abide by that regular
those requirements that needs a change
in one of the floor plans
we would have to go away and talk to the
applicant about that as a separate
matter that's
um that's not not the application before
us we're dealing with the application
before us
if that is something members feel very
strongly on and possibly wish to head
towards a refusal issue
then i would need to take further advice
from the case officer and discuss that
with with the legal officer sorry about
that i wasn't cutting across either of
you too i just wanted clarity on
on that um counselor melon was that was
there something else
that that you you had landscape and the
height wasn't it
yeah um there was a question about the
height of three boundary walls which
they were seeking to be clarified
and they suggested the addition of
fencing into the hedges to protect them
from
people walking through them i think
basically is what it seemed to be
um so i assume that's something i think
those
are things that we've picked up along
the way certainly in terms of
the um the landscape boundary the
officer referred to
around the periphery of the site there
is post and wire fencing either side to
essentially protect the trees as they
they look to establish and as the case
office indicated the
the heights of the walls are are the the
standard heights within the development
as as you expect
okay one more exactly please do um i
don't know if you're aware that um
in battle lash they've got a little
project going to
support house martins and some of the
other developments are
have been putting house martin cups
under the eaves um
the secretary of the uh house martin
protection league lives in bad one ash
so
the question is are they going to put
the question is would you be willing to
put those on
yeah i mean as as the case i've just
indicated under the conditions both on
the outline and potentially here
there is the requirement for ecological
enhancements
and they could form part of that yes
thank you excellent any further
questions for the applicant counsellor
casten
thank you madam chairman um i haven't
seen a detailed
archaeological report for this is is the
one and i've
missed it um if so can you um can you
tell me what
area was investigated and what the means
was
um how how it was investigated please
yeah um we have worked with the county
archaeologists we do on all our sites
um i understand that original five
percent trial trenching was undertaken
um with the outline application the
results of that were that further
investigation of this western end of the
site
roughly where the attenuation basin is
in the area there
was more recently excavated hence why
you probably saw the
diggers on the site again that was under
the supervision of suffolk county county
archaeology
and in due course under the requirements
of the condition appended to the outline
plan of commission
there will be a report of that
excavation submitted to the county
archaeologist to
sign off
okay thank you any further questions for
the applicant
no thank you very much indeed if you'd
like to return to your seat thank you
very much indeed
um oh mr smith
wire under your foot yes your feet are
caught in the water
um and now rob will read out uh
councillor
board member rick mayer's um
presentation to us if you would please
thank you chair
so from board member councillor right
mayor councillors i apologize for not
attending the planning committee in
person but personal circumstances make
this impossible
having discussed application dc 20 04785
with the badwallash parish council they
have requested that i make the comments
listed below
over recent years badwa ash has been the
focus of considerable development
well in advance of the levels required
within the emerging joint local plan
whilst accepting that the principle of
development for the site
on land north of the broadway badwalesh
has
been established in the planning
permission issued under dc 7
dc 18 0257 the parish council remains
concerned
over the amount of development within
the village and the damage this is doing
to the quality of life of local
residents
and that they enjoy regarding the
reserve matters under consideration they
have the following comments
the open space included within the
proposed site layout is limited and will
encourage
younger residents to access recreational
facilities in the centre of the village
along a narrow
road that is not equipped with footpaths
they would like to add their support to
the comments made by the environmental
health officer
regarding the sustainability issues they
look forward to having sight of a
sustainability and energy strategy
covering the site which should act to
minimise environmental impact during
both construction and occupation
given the amount of approved development
in the area biodiversity is in
is of increasing concern to local
residents and the parish council
strongly supports
suggestions made by the suffolk wildlife
trust including the provision of
integrated swift and bat boxes
on all dwellings together with the
installation of hedgehog permeable
fencing
the broadway is a narrow unlit road
infrastructure provisions in the form of
street lighting
should be included in the conditions
attached
to any approval of the current
application to ensure that resident
residents are able to cross bound
broadway safely at all times of day and
night
whilst accessing the village fire the
only safe pedestrian route through the
development
opposite council there
thank you very much i can now open the
matter up for debate
if anybody would like to start us off
thank you very much indeed
councillor humphreys mum chair thank you
um i think on the face of it this is
fairly good development and we just look
at the reserve matters
in front of us again just like the
previous one there are very little
things that we could actually turn this
down over
i've listened to the ward members
comments but actually i'll take you to
the badwell
parish comments um which art has
detailed
and it just says as a result that parish
council we
would be withholding approval until
matters regarding drainage issues raised
by environmental agency and the
confirmation regarding installation of
fire hydrants have been addressed
also concern about development should
match part for the building regulations
they were there are only comments and
we've already heard they've been
satisfied by condition
so the concerns of badwell parish
council
have been satisfied as far as i'm
concerned
it's really good to see such a good
layout of different types of properties
including bungalows
and including one bedroom bungalows for
the affordable housing mix
and i think that's really good as well
the buffer around the whole area
uh 12 feet that's that's quite
considerable actually um
which is refreshing to see the only
thing i'd like to comment on is the tree
that a few people have already commented
on and my question is
well sort of debate point i suppose why
can't a tree be moved rather than felled
um in the second world war they move
massive mature trees
that's camouflage airfields so i'm sure
it's possible to move one tree
to satisfy the environmental impact of
cutting that tree down
just by moving it and i know it's not as
simple as that but it is part of
landscaping and i just like to think
people perhaps think about alternatives
to felling
it's called moving so um maybe you
should think about that
um i've got no
issues with this talk honestly but i
would like to put that condition in
about the swift boxes that's been
discussed by councillor mellon
and pretty much agreed with
i think uh by the agent
thank you thank you any further debate
please
answer constant
thank you very much madam chairman um
yes i i agree with a lot of what was
just said
the um we've already we've already
agreed the um principle of development
on the site which um
covers a lot of the issues that we've um
we've talked about the um the tree
moving i think is quite
quite an interesting idea um but the um
the thing about fellain trees for me is
where that
um that um
wood that that final um product
ends up um if it goes into wood burners
all the um
everything the tree's done over at some
time is completely lost and and
um i think um there's other ways to deal
with a um
with um the biomass from am tree after
you cut it down
but um yeah layout
um good mix it looks like a good quality
design
the the houses architecturally look
quite nice
the um archaeological side of things
i think that site could be potentially
quite a um
quite a high yielding archaeological um
site
but that is taken care of if um suffolk
county
council are looking after the um
the results of the um the dig that's
gonna be done um so as far as i'm
concerned i think this is
something that i would approve of in
reserve matters
um thank you very much thank you very
much indeed
any further debate that's the melon
thank you
thank you chair um yeah i know bad boy
quite well it's obviously part of my
county division um
and it has an excellent chip shop which
i regularly
go to um and as a community is is quite
an active little community
um they've got a shop there
unfortunately the school is closed
but they've got an active parish council
and um
you know there's some development come
along this one is a bit of an odd one it
really does extend the village boundary
out
um beyond a sort of current built form
um the broadway is kind of a boundary to
the village really
but obviously we're not debating that
today that the principle is established
broadway is only really a single track
road
um although i think it is national speed
limit
uh which is a bit of an odd one um but
it seems to me there is reasonable
pedestrian connectivity from this site
into the heart of the village through
through the one that's been
which is being built out at the moment
um i still have a bit of a struggle
that some of the recommendations from
our council teas and officers
make it into the recommendation and
condition and some don't and maybe it's
my
sort of lack of understanding of all the
planning rules but um
it does seem to me that we've got
something in the papers which says
sustainability and energy strategy must
be provided and we can't seem to
do that even though we've declared a
climate emergency so that's a bit of a
struggle for me but
otherwise um yeah this this one is one i
could uh
support thank you chat thank you
councillor melon
anyone councillor stringer thank you
yeah uh i
don't really want to spoil a party but i
i don't think i'm going to be supporting
this
i'm getting really frustrated at how we
gleefully say how we can't actually
bring about what we call sustainable
development
because of quaint little rules that we
impose upon ourselves
we've got a design here now where
virtually all of the affordable housing
roofs
face either east or west so
if if we want to generate electricity to
fill those heat pumps within those
buildings
then the ability to do that will be
marginalized or come at a greater
expense
and that expense is highly likely to be
at the taxpayer's fee
equally with disability uh
requirements for accessibility we
honestly arguing
that we shouldn't be doing this and then
we can't do this because of some quaint
rule
one in four of us will need adaptations
to our housing
during our lifetime because of
disability if we can't build it in at
the start
we then retrofit it which costs
phenomenally more
and this council spends almost half a
million pounds a year doing that
and that cost is only going to increase
if we don't design it properly in the
first place
and the suggestion about the tree i i
get why the quirk of
the rules is why we possibly can't
discuss the tree
actually relocating the tree the co2
emissions from the machinery digging the
hole
would probably offset any carbon that
that tree would would
do its lifetime but why we couldn't
design a site around this
and it would have been needed bigger
sight lines because it is a national
speed limit
well hang on i would imagine the first
thing that will happen after this site's
built is
the speed limit will change therefore
the visibility lines would have needed
to bring less
but the result would have been we filled
the tree anyway because of the
arbitrary rules we put upon ourselves so
i frankly won't be supporting this one
purely because of all that lack of join
up uh
thank you chair thank you um just one
moment if we can
any further comments from the floor
no councillor norrish you want to say
anything no
council humphreys again thank you i'm
sure thank you um can you just put the
slide back up please at the
site so um just point out
if you would the affordable housing
again
um these yes that's got some self-facing
uh continue around and then so southwest
is also a good position
and and that one also south facing so
some of them do sell face
and as we know it doesn't have to point
south it's the most efficient without a
doubt
but it doesn't have to point itself to
use solar panels or pv
panels um and as far as moving the tree
i'm suggesting manpower with shovels
which is satisfy everybody i'm sure
thank you very much
thank you councillor humphreys um well
i've listened to what people have said
and i've read the notes
and like councillor stringer i did
actually bring up the mention of the
tree right at the beginning and at
briefing
we don't know what sort of tree it is so
councillor custom i don't know whether
we can turn it into woodturning
items but a very thoughtful comment
i don't know what sort it is but it
really is a shame that it has to go but
i do understand there will be additional
planting
i made a note right at the beginning i
like the variety and i think there's
good variety here
and it is a location that had been
earmarked for development and i think as
councillor humphreys has said the parish
council's original concerns have been
met
so i like the idea of what we have
before us
having said that um i would need a
proposer and a seconder if people are
minded
to approve the application councillor
humphreys
i'm chair thank you i'd like to propose
approval thank you and councillor castin
happy 2nd thank you thank you very much
so rob if you can arrange that for us
thank you chair just to confirm because
the point was raised earlier about
a condition regarding the i believe it
was house martin's i think there was a
point raised about swifts now
i'd ask members to excuse my ecological
ignorance
but is there a difference between the
two yep thank you
so i'll make sure that i get the right
terminology in the
vote so and it would be could mr payment
you could i just asked for some advice
on some wording
um with regards to that
was it house martin's or swift's in the
end of tomorrow it was house martin
councilman melanie i better change my
wording then all right okay
um i think what you've already got in
your papers
is uh enhanced biodiversity strategy
uh conditions and i suppose in what i
would probably suggest to do that
you're essentially just adding
additional peace to that which is
and this shall include um a scheme for
house martin boxers to the
uh relevant dwellings so i would just
simply add that to that condition
effectively so
we would be requiring a scheme uh
for uh best boxers uh for house martins
as part of the ecology uh uh
biodiversity strategy that's
they're conditioned cups they're called
sorry to
be technical but yeah i'm sorry well
uh well we will i think
i'll put as long as the little birds are
mentioned they'll get rid of it for
nesting
for nesting appropriate i don't want to
call them cups just in case we had lots
of cups but on
houses yeah
just to check sorry john it was for the
for the house was as part of the what
what statement was it
was the condition um
uh you have the biodiversity enhancement
strategy thank you
i just want to make a quite a cheeky
point that that the orientation of
no i think we finished the debate okay
no no i'm just i'm just suggesting just
so you were aware
the orientation needs to be on north
facing walls so those
houses that are orientated for me the
wrong way
will also not support these cuts because
you all then cook the birds
and we it sort of miscounts the
humphries
for the condition then uh maybe where
possible
yes where possible
secondary you happy with where possible
yes i'm happy with that thing
you for that no
i apologize that's just deleted that at
all
after i'll just ask for a couple of
minutes apologies
just take it slowly
so the additional condition for nesting
points to be provided for house martin's
where possible
as a part of the
biodiversity
enhancement trust strategy thank you
thank you chair and thank you members
for bearing with me there so
if members want to go to the modern.gov
app and go to the plus sign in the top
right hand corner
and go on the subsection on voting slash
attendance the vote will now show in
progress
councillor humphreys can i please take
your vote thank you
[Music]
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and there's six votes four
and one against so that is carried
thank you very much indeed everybody
so if we move on
[Music]
to dc 21
000 584 land between red house and
honeysuckle cottage wrecking hall and
sean you're going to introduce this
matter again for us please
thank you very much
oh this one again
are we all gone
[Music]
john have you got it on your
presentation
is it on your screen sean yeah so
are you hit but is it presentate is it
presenting
[Music]
go back in here
excellent
[Music]
okay thank you chair
so this application is in the north of
the district
um in wrecking hall
in land in the street
so the application site again is hatched
in the
pink hatching with the orange outline
and this is the main
street in wrecking hall leading up
towards
the marketplace
you can see the pattern of development
along the frontage and the application
site makes use of an existing access
into land at the rear
so in terms of a slightly wider context
you can see the development along the
street
this is garden house lane and there's
open landscape land to the
west
so the site lies in the conservation
area which is
the purple line and this hatched area
the brown line is the settlement
boundary
so it lies outside the flood zones which
are
off to the west and um
nearby listed buildings are highlighted
in orange
this one here is obviously nearest the
site
which is the old four horseshoes
so in the conservation area the policy
requirements are for us to consider
any harm which might be caused within
the conservation area
to conservation area itself to listed
buildings
or non-designated heritage assets and
balancing those against
any public benefits
the site edged in red between the red
house
and honeysuckle cottage
so in terms of the site plan the
proposal is making use of the
existing vehicular access which goes to
land at the rear of the red house
and this is the proposed dwelling in
this
position here excuse me
um it's quite useful to look at the um
floor area and i do have some
dimensioned plans
as well coming up but to just look at
the scale of
that floor area compared to for example
the traditional scale properties on the
road
frontage these buildings here
are outbuildings to bradgate house which
is
located approximately here
so vehicular access parking and turning
in this vicinity here
so the agent provided um some dimensions
to the site boundaries uh this dimension
here being in the region of 1.8 meters
and this is about 3.4 meters
about 6 meters here to the rear boundary
fence
um and this does actually say 5.8 but i
think actually it should be more like
um i think it's been scaled it should
really be about 11.3
meters to that southwestern boundary
uh the landscape proposal does again
indicate the position of the dwelling
towards the rear of the site
shows a cherry tree there being removed
the retention of that tree and the
provision
of some boundary landscaping
against the rear boundary of the red
house
[Music]
this is just for a little bit of context
because this
point was raised by the heritage officer
this is just to show
an application back in 2003 and there
has been quite a history on this site
this is the street frontage and this
proposed a dwelling along the street
frontage and then
going back into the site with car
parking access
through an archway to the rear but
obviously that that
permission has expired but as it's
referred to
in some of the correspondence i'm just
bringing that to members attention
[Music]
and also just for context
this application was submitted last year
2020
and was withdrawn but was more of an
l shape and had a third
bedroom in that position there and a bit
more activity
along that part of the site but that was
withdrawn
and these are just to skim through the
plans and elevations of
that previously withdrawn
application
so the proposal before us today
is for a two-story but the first floor
accommodation of two bedrooms
um and a little study area are
really lit by roof lights so it's sort
of one and a half
story on the ground floor a bathroom and
an open plan
kitchen living dining room and as
mentioned
two bedrooms on the first floor
the agent has confirmed that the floor
area
is about 115 square meters
and i suggested that we look at in
comparison to the scale of the frontage
development
in the street but also um
again for comparison purposes um
a two-bedroom property um
like the ones that we've been
considering at hopkins homes are two
bedroom properties normally around about
80 to 85 square meters roughly obviously
they vary and a three bed would be about
90
to 100 square meters this
would total about 156 square meters if
it was a full
first floor there are two elements of
a void area in these two positions
here so the floor area is given as 115
square meters
so the sections again just show that the
first floor isn't
um full height with their roof lights
proposed
the elevation so this elevation here is
the one
which faces towards the access and
therefore facing towards the street
this is the elevation um the rear
elevation
and this elevation faces the garden area
you can see
two roof lights and solar panels
and that's the northeastern elevation
there wouldn't be any overlooking
from those high level roof lights to the
neighboring property
the proposed materials are indicated as
a red brick plinth
vertical timber boarding and pen tiles
to the roof
section um indicates that there's about
a meter difference
between the ground level on the adjacent
plot
which is brad gate and these are out
buildings which serve
that property
[Music]
this plan again is just showing the
visibility display
which is required and
skim's red house in that direction
and facing northwest highways are happy
with that and it is in fact the use of
an existing
vehicular access rather than a new one
so if i can show some photographs to put
the site in context the application site
is actually
positioned here but these trees are not
necessarily on the site they're
adjacent or to the rear of the site but
the application site is tucked in there
and we're looking towards the
application site and up towards
bottisdale marketplace
so obviously this is the character of
the frontage development
and the flint property here is the
listed building that's mentioned
other properties have been considered
and are considered in the neighborhood
plan
as non-designated assets
[Music]
so this is the entrance into the site in
this location
here there is an existing dropped curb
so looking into the site these are the
outbuildings on the adjacent
site
this is honeysuckle cottage so now this
is the um the site boundary the
northeast
boundary of the site and as you can see
the site is generally
um sort of cut grass uh rough
rough grass so looking to the adjacent
properties there and this is a brad gate
just peeping into the photograph
and this is looking back towards the
road with the fence boundary and a
bit of a meter or so difference in the
ground level
these are the outbuildings on the
adjacent parcel of land
actually i'll just go back looking to
the rear you can see the um
the the trees generally um behind the
site
this is looking across so the proposed
dwelling
is roughly um in this location
here
so this is then the rear boundary of the
red house
that's the red house and this is the
rear of the listed
building that's been mentioned
again that just gives a bit of a clearer
view back towards the road
frontage
the rear of the um dwellings and you can
see
um this photograph actually was taken in
connection with the previous application
in 2020
so that that might be the cherry
to be removed or which may now have been
removed
the arboricultural officers raised no
objection
to the removal of the tree
[Music]
so this is again looking towards the
vegetation at the outside the
application site
that's just beyond the site
and then the existing vehicle access and
there's on street
parking but this is the visibility
display
running right across the corner of that
property
in the south direction and looking
to the north
[Music]
i think in your late papers um you've
had an updated comment from the parish
council
and also in the uh representations
um there was an additional comment
um which was talking about um
the the the scheme doesn't present uh
public benefit
when the harm is assessed
so the principle of the development in
the conservation area in the setting of
the listed buildings
has been assessed and comments have been
received
by the heritage officer the policies
of the local neighborhood plan have also
been taken
into consideration and it's
considered that the there is harm
to those assets um and the applications
recommended
for refusal as in the papers thank you
thank you for that um i've got a couple
of questions is
where would the parking for red house be
and where would it now go if
this is um my understanding is
that um the occupiers of red house
don't park on the site i think there's a
question there's land ownership
it's different different land ownership
so the parking for red house
is on the street i assume and would
continue to be on street oh i see
oh i wasn't wasn't aware of that um and
this is a call in by the member is it
it is yeah um and um
there's two elements of void areas in
the
upstairs of the proposed dwelling um
what are they for exactly if they're
just voids what are they
what are they are they part of the
stairway or or are they
um cupboard space or what what are they
exactly they look quite large
well i think it's just um
a design feature i suppose uh so the
section here
show that this is one of the void areas
at the first floor
um and that's the other so there's a
kind of walkway like we often see in
barn conversions really her bedroom at
one end in the bedroom at the other and
it's linked by right away thank you for
that and the
outbuildings that are on the other side
what they look rather smart what are
they
are they garages or something what are
these uh i think one of them's garaging
um i'm not sure whether the other one
might be some sort of annex or
outbuildings but there's no overlooking
anyway no is there no
no that's confirmed that's good thank
you i'm sorry about that um i'd rather
indulge your bachelor's strength
thank you chair uh you said there was
some identified
harm can you tell us what level that
harm
is
yes the heritage officer um has
commented on the application um
just find his exact
wording
well he highlights the need to avoid
harm
in any case um but it's a low level of
less than substantial
okay thank you that's helpful
[Music]
cancel casting first
thank you um in one of the slides
there's a photo looking down
the street um and there's a blue house
which i think is the four horseshoes
no the the four horseshoes is the uh
flint property
the blue one is a bit further down no
i'm not sure
it doesn't matter but it's not being
housed all four horseshoes there on one
of your
slides is a you're looking down the
street with the um
with the blue house there is there a
visual impact to the street from this
development or is it or is it covered by
those trees in the background
just go back to
the site plan so the blue house is
um roughly here i think
um and there are
outbuildings uh which is the back of the
um listed building so
there's was your question if there's an
impact from
looking if you're at the blue house
looking towards the site
yeah so the the easy way of saying it is
will you be able to see it from the
street if you drive down the street
past those houses will you see the roof
line of the house
yes um
you you might you might see a bit of the
roofline i'll go back to the photograph
in question then we can have a look at
that
so you might catch a glimpse of the roof
somewhere about there possibly
can i actually ask a question on that
point if it may
on the site itself the the level of
ground seems higher than the
outbuildings
on the right hand side does the level of
ground
equal the same height as the street as
you're going into the site or does it
raise up
i think the site is fairly level going
in from the street but it's just that
that adjacent
plot is further down
so i think the answer to the question is
that there may be limited views
from such as this view uh but it is
quite hard to tell because obviously the
trees and how you
the indivisibility is going to be
limited um the main view obviously is
going to be from the
entrance itself uh to the street scene
thank you this argument made in the
paper for the linear design of the
street
and the fact that this would be breaking
that linear
flow um can you confirm um
how far the linear actually is because
looking at this map or this aerial
photograph doesn't look very linear to
me because
further along the street by about 100
meters if if that there's a
almost a housing estate and if you come
back this way so the south
uh west again about 100 meters this
house is not in a linear flow
so how how firm is that argument about
the linear
design of this village
i think um the the main
area of in the immediate locality of the
site obviously these properties here
are purely frontage um as
are some on the other side of the road
there is a property set back at this
point
um and there are elements which um
have been identified by um by the agent
by the application
of development in depth such as brad
gate house next door and a few other
properties
but those are either a conversion of an
existing barn or
it was new development permitted in
about 1989 or so
before we had the stronger policies
in terms of um resisting any harm to
conservation areas
so in in this particular locality
there is frontage development yes when
you look at the aerial photographs
there is more modern development that is
either set back
in fact if i go
i'll have to go right back to the
aerial photographs
actually this this shows it so the
conservation area so here is the row of
um sort of traditionally proportioned
frontage development that we've been
talking about
um the this is in depth but it's only
um in uh single depth if you like it's
set around a green
um this is brad gate house
here and this property here i think is a
barn conversion
and then further north there is a bit
more development in depth
but looking at the second reason for
refusal which is in terms of the
um restricted size of the site
that adjacent properties on a much
larger site and and there isn't the
associated cramping and impact
on amenity that you get on this smaller
site
there are instances of development in
depth but the main
location of the frontage development
that we're concerned about in this
instance is
in the immediate locality and again
you've got frontage development across
the road
although it then gives in to more modern
larger
um sort of a state development behind
thank you yes councillor norris thank
you thank you
on page 235
at the top under b representations there
are a number of
objections listed the last one of which
says
encroaches on land not owned by
applicant would the officer clarify that
well the the question of land ownership
um
is uh has been raised as an issue in
connection with this application
if the agent has um
uh you know i have been advised that the
correct certificates
have been served and that the land
ownership is as stated
another party claims otherwise if there
is a land ownership issue at the end of
the day
that impacts on the development then
that is a private
matter beyond our consideration as far
as i'm concerned
i've been advised that the correct
format of application has been submitted
i see
okay and i think ian can confirm that we
can
uh should members be uh wanting to
approve something they can approve it
but the matter thereafter
is beyond us yeah the case office is
quite right that is an issue that does
arise in
these meetings from time to time and the
the case officer stated the law quite
rightly and i don't need to
say any more than that that i agree
you get well yes you don't need planning
permission
to you don't need to own land in order
to make in order to obtain planning
permission as long as you serve the
correct
certificates and if there is an argument
about the certificates we
unless the error is demonstrable through
evidence such as the land registry
we have to act on what we are told which
is what the case officer has done
clearly and
obviously a planning permission is no
not much practical use if you don't
actually own the land but then that is a
matter for private law
afterwards thank you thank you for that
any further questions for the officer no
thank you very much uh we don't have a
representative from the parish
or an objector or a supporter so now um
on behalf of the applicant we have david
barker if you would like to come along
and have three minutes if you would
please thank you very much
good morning i'm david barker the agent
for this application
i speak on behalf of joe and law or
laura irving who can't be here because
they're both ill with covid
they wanted to speak to you in person so
have given me this to read on their
behalf
my wife and i live a short distance away
for us this plot is a lot more than a
development project
laura was born and raised in the village
the village is home to her mother and
her brother's family and we are very
much part of the community
this is about building our family home
in a village so dear to us
and not something for profit but
something we can be proud of
our current house is too small for a
family the application site has been in
the family for a long time
i'm a carpenter and we'll build the
house above the usual standard for a
home
with an airtight envelope excellent
insulation
heat recovery ventilation solar hot
water and rain water harvesting
i find this type of construction a
rarity for new builds the large
developments never do it
and it's something we will take a lot of
pride in bringing to the village
we would be happy to have a planning
condition to provide the details
we submitted an application last year
and had comments from the officers about
heritage and overlooking
we withdrew the application to deal with
these issues
last year's application has strong
support from the parish who took their
neighbourhood plan policies into account
the proposal is smaller and we have
support from the parish and two
immediate neighbours
the objectives have committed because
we're in a family legal dispute with
them about the site boundary
our lawyer is very clear that we are in
the right but the dispute
still not go away the heritage officer
finds only
a low level of harm commenting that
development is characteristically one
plot deep
this is not the case as you will see
from your slides two and three
there is a lot of development behind the
frontage houses our house is designed in
the style of the barn and similar
outbuildings are common behind houses
and there are examples nearby
they say the development will close the
gap with red house the area is already
enclosed by mature trees and is already
built up
red house is not a listed building the
parachute has a neighborhood plan
support this application and don't feel
it harms the area
two neighbours have written in support
they do not think the cars will affect
them
the site already has a road access and
we could use it for parking now
we're happy to properly fence and put
trees along the boundaries to make sure
we do not disturb the neighbours
we are only building a small house so it
will be in keeping
the 2003 permission for a house on the
front could not be built now as the site
is not in one ownership
and there are services in part of the
site which we could not build over
we see lots of new homes being built in
fields in the area this is a very
sustainably located site
government policy says that we should
prioritize the use
of unused and sustainable sites the
planners want benefits from this
application
we are reusing a vacant well located
site the energy efficiency measures are
important
it's a house type that is in need and
there will be economic benefits
the neighborhood plan specifically wants
homes for young people in the community
i hope you will support this and i'll be
happy to answer any questions
thank you well first of all will you
pass on our good wishes
uh to the applicants with their current
uh medical issues thank you
very worrying thank you um right does
yes councillor stringer yeah thank you
thank you chair uh page 273
in our bundles so i'll take this off a
bit easier
i'm really confused about how the size
of the building
and the size of of the gaps between it
and the boundaries
because if i take one of those and scale
it up the 5.8 meters if that's 5.8
meters
then this building is 36 square meters
over two floors
which it clearly isn't so can i have
clarification as to
those dimensions as stated on those
plans could i have those
corrected uh yes let me have a look or
just clarified
and the actual dimension of the building
would be if i if i may just intercede on
that one
um when the presentation was made the
5.8 we we've actually said it's when you
scale the plan it's around about 11.3
okay uh meters um the others are roughly
correct
but okay we think there's an error in
the labeling of that one
okay so that's 11.3 meters on the long
run through the long
um boundary between the yep sort of
french doors and the sun
and the so using those dimensions if i
try and scale the building either it
then makes it ginormous so can you tell
me how big the building is
the building um the floor ground for the
internal floor area of the building is
115 square meters
yeah but that's split over two floors
and voids that's right what are the
dimensions of the structure
that's two two numbers i've got that on
one of my plans i think
it's point four by eleven point six but
let me do that
that sounds about right i've got that
twelve point six by six point two
was the dimension you gave me okay
[Music]
i've got a scale rule on a plan so i'll
do it here
now internally is
[Music]
i mean the internal measurements 11.6
i really wanted the external but okay
you don't see the internals
[Music]
12.
0.3 and then
6.1 brilliant that's all i want today
thank you thank you
thank you very much council stringer any
further questions for the
agent please mr barker
thank you very much indeed if you'd like
to take your seat thank you very much
indeed
so we now have a statement from
councillor fleming who obviously makes
her apologies and rob will now read that
out for us please thank you very much
so came from all counsellor
jessica fleming
i write on behalf of the applicant for
this application which has been
recommended for refusal
and apologize for not being in front
being in front of you in person
firstly i believe that the proposal for
a new fairly modest
dwelling in the position identified
represents an overall benefit
to the local area notwithstanding its
location in the conservation area
any development in the conservation area
cannot but
change its character at some level and a
degree of change or harm is generally
accepted
in planning decision making the heritage
officer has identified a low level of
less than substantial harm associated
with this proposal
to overcome this the architect has gone
to some lengths to work
with the heritage officer and has
proposed a design that
is in keeping with other buildings and
the heritage setting
as well as offering substantial
sustainable
features which can be conditioned refer
to the design and access statement
paragraph 5.25
a professional heritage assessment has
been prepared
a key question is is a possible low
level of harm sufficient grounds for
refusal
given the benefits of providing an
additional modestly sized home in a
desirable and suitable location
i do not believe that this is the case
and that the very small amount of harm
if any does not justify refusal nor does
it contravene relevant
planning policy i would like to address
the general acceptability of the
proposal
as evidenced by comments from neighbours
and the parish council
the proposal has elicited two public
comments in support
including the adjacent east side
property as well as the statement of
in support from the parish council i was
present when the application was
discussed in public and the general
feeling was very positive
that this is this new dwelling would be
a great improvement upon the present
situation
and would provide welcome housing for a
local family
i hope members will have seen the parish
council comments in support as well as
the other public supporting comments
the committee report identifies two
letters of objection
i would like to point out that the
comment objection from the neighbor at
red house concerns failure to be
notified of the development
and the other objection is from a person
who lives in halston and appears to
center on loss of immunity
the location is within the village
envelope and does not conflict with the
aims
and vision of the wrecking hall
bottasdale neighborhood plan
nor with the relevant policies in the
local plan or mppf
it enjoys active local support which is
somewhat unusual for most planning
applications
i've visited the site and enclosed two
photos which may or may not be able to
view
having considered the various issues
raised by officers and countless
consultees i see no grounds for refusal
and a substantial benefit for from
enabling this
small-scale development to proceed i
therefore ask members to consider the
application objectively and to grant
consent
thank you councillor jessica fleming
thank you very much so i now open the
matter up for debate
we'd like to start us off oh sorry yes
john
john you may say something i'm going to
make a point of
clarification if i may and i need ian's
help here um
in terms of what was just uh read out um
the starting line was that
they were writing on behalf of the
applicant not themselves
is that relevant or appropriate if i may
ask
um well i think it's
the award ward members are invited to
speak as ward members i don't i think
councillor fleming is an experienced
counselor who understands that it might
just have been a choice of words that
could have been not used but i don't
want that misrepresentative
obviously if i'm looking at this from
the public point of view and later on
which is a challenge any decision made
on that basis
i just wanted to clarify that point um
equally um i think the
there was a point about the number of
representations received
can i also just ask the case officer
just to confirm i think it's five
representations have been received in
terms of uh comments and objections is
that
correct not the two that's mentioned
two two letters of support have been
received um and then now there are
two two letters of objection
right but not just two on their own so
those four in total
yeah thank you yeah
right thank you for the uh update so
you're happy well yes i mean the the
difficult because jessica isn't here to
say whether she's
speaking i understand only half or
the um in support of indeed the agent mr
barker has spoken in support
in place of the applicant who's
unfortunately on can't be here for
health reasons
that's and it's obviously very common
practice for an agent to speak any way
regardless of that
um but i think as long as we understand
the point and
members have received the ward members
comments and
um we can proceed yes
thank you thank you for that clarity
right who'd like to start
counsellor custom
so um this meetings played out a little
bit differently to um
how i expected when i was reading this a
week ago i was looking at this
development thinking i can't really see
a massive problem
with this development it's um
i i thought the ward counselor was going
to speak out it would it had been
brought to here
because there was a big problem and i
thought what am i missing
it it doesn't seem like i'm i've missed
a lot in this
the um the depth of development
i there's out buildings that are very
well developed
almost you know further back well they
are further back than this
development when you look at the map
like councillor humphreys says
when you look above it is built out it's
not a single
road um alongside the street
it's it's got depth to it it's um
i think we've got to as always we've got
to look at what benefit
this brings to the harm but i am
really struggling to see um a huge
amount of harm from this
the um i don't believe it really stands
out from the street
i don't really believe that you'll know
it's there from
one once it's built the um
the visibility display for that kind of
road i think is
acceptable the only thing i will say
about it is there is a
bit of a lack of space in there too to
maneuver a car
and you don't really want to have cars
backing out onto that road
but in the plans there is a sort of
turning area
so um yeah i don't know if i'm going
against the grain
with this but i don't i don't really
have a massive problem um
with this development i think it's using
land that some
you know better than using a field in a
sustainable location
and it's making good use of that land
thank you for that council humphreys
mom chair thank you um much the same
vain actually i'll just go back to the
award counselor's comments
slightly misleading actually when she
says they've been you know
almost enthusiastic about the support
this has had when in fact it's just two
so slightly misleading on what she said
and again poor choice of words
she shouldn't uh represent the applicant
in my in my mind
but that's that's been said now um
although the regulations have changed
over time
um with conservation areas and the way
we build and how we build
the precedence already been set um and
it's depth
you only have to go 50 meters to 100
meters north of it north west sorry
and uh sorry north east or south west
and the
town is or the village has been built
out significantly
the outbuildings you spoke about one of
them looked like is you could almost
move into it
so we're not just talking about a shed
or a garage we're talking about
substantial outbuildings
uh almost the size of this property i
would argue
um talking about the size of the
property this scale i'm a little bit
confused with so if i go to page 273
273 shows you a a plan view
of the property now i'm looking at the
size of the car
and i'm turning the length of the car
along the width of the house
and it's only just a little bit bigger
than the width of the car the length of
the car
so i think the scale on the diagram
seems a little bit odd also the
measurement from the
um let's see what direction are we the
north eastern side
to the fence line 3.8 meters is that say
not got my glasses on it's about that
isn't it if you
move that or just take a piece of paper
as i did and put it on the house
the house is a little bit
wider than that so we talked about six
point something meters didn't we
so the car size and six point meters to
me doesn't make sense an 18 foot long
car
um the the scale of this picture is
misleading
and i'd like confirmation of the size of
that property the width of that property
because
that picture just doesn't make sense
or am i getting it wrong can we just
have clarity from the officer if you can
answer that question before we proceed
well i i haven't scaled it i've looked
and i i did seek
confirmation from the sorry sought
confirmation from the agent
um a while ago for the dimensions
um which i mean he's reiterated
just now um that the figures are just
over 12 meters by just over six meters
in plan so are you worried councillor
humphreys that the cars are too big or
the house is too big or the cars are too
small in the house i'm just envious of
the limousines that you've
yeah huge limousines on the drive i
think if we're going to do this in
future that then we need that
really to represent a realistic view of
what we're actually going to vote on
it's quite important because looking at
that you go well that's not very wide
how can that be a family home two
bedrooms and it's only just wider than a
car's length
um so it sort of fires back at the
argument that this is going to be a
family's home
and that's why these diagrams are
important but that side
now we've clarified it's six meters or
thereabouts that's probably sufficient
um no objections from the parish council
i get that it's in conservation here
i've already discussed that which
we talked about depth the president's
already been set
this isn't a linear village 50 meters
of this a linear in my in my view and i
might be wrong but that's the way i see
it
anything else and a scale
looking at the site the scale i think
it's fairly good
i think it's suitable it's certainly
bigger than some of the modern houses we
see coming before us
in terms of available space garden
driveway et cetera so i've got no
objection with that either so
like you councillor counselor cassandra
initially i'm like oh okay but i've
changed my opinion
um i haven't got a real issue with this
thank you
that's a stringer yeah just to uh uh
help about the
the cars are actually perfectly to scale
because you have to show cars at being
four and a half meters length on a
planning drawing okay
so actually at four and a half meters
that's correct
uh it's not there to show you a scale
it's there to show you that a
reasonably sized car could technically
fit in the highways
department normally asked for them to be
shown four and a half meters long which
that is shown four and a half meters
long
uh so it's not far out although what
does confuse is the the measurements
around it but i think
we've got to the accurate measurements
now the building
yeah i i too don't have major concerns
about this going forward and i'm
slightly surprised to see us
uh holding up an objection quite a
fearsome objection
on a low level of less than substantial
harm
i get the thing about it being linear
but i equally
really dislike pastiche which is what
that earlier
approval was a little linear thing that
you drive a car
under which that would have been really
safe trying to drive in and out of that
i i think the solution you've got here
is to
not trying to harp back to the past but
actually look to something that's
deliberately modern that reflects
some kind of outbuilding which i
actually quite like
i don't one bit i find misleading in in
the ward members
submission was how this would be a
modest
building it isn't let's be brutally
honest this is 12 meters long
you know in the national space standards
you could fit two
two-bedroom dwellings onto the same
footprint
having said that i would i want to see
two dwellings in there yeah that
footprint
it probably wouldn't be appropriate to
the setting etc etc
so if you could build in some serious
sustainability measures in this
i would say this is actually a good
solution to creating a housing
opportunity that's
inside the settlement boundary and
within the bounds of a
of a current neighborhood plan thank you
chair
thank you councillor any further
comments
council of war boys please well i think
a continuation of what's been said
really i i do drive along
the street in rickenhall through into
boston
and you do get the impression of a
linear village
but on closer inspection there is
extensive development
behind those frontages uh
driving along i don't think you'd
actually notice
the entrance into this building or the
building behind it would
i think it would be lost um normally i
would come down
on the side of the heritage officer and
really support
um
the need to protect a heritage and and
as a conservation area
i i think his um part of his argument
was that this
that the less than the low level of less
than substantial arm was not um
mitigated if you if you like by the um
the low level of benefit of this two
bedroom house um but after listening to
the presentation by
the agent and and the ward member
it's quite clear that the the benefits
of the community which
are echoed by the parish council
actually
are quite good quite good it's for a
local resident
um it's a small house
um and it's going to be built
to sort of very high environmental and
energy efficient standards
so the the benefits are actually perhaps
greater
and would justify the low level
of less than substantial harm so
yes i find i'm coming down
on the side of it it is a small site and
there has been
i've seen other sites where there's been
developing developments in back
gardens which have really um
undermine the amenity value of the
neighboring properties
um but this doesn't seem to be the
situation here where the
development could fit in there quite
quite well um
so i i've tended to sort of come down in
favor of supporting
development and not the recommendation
of the officer
thank you for that counselor john you
just wanted to say something and then
i'll come to you councillor norris if we
may
and i just um asked members in their
terms of their debate
um just there's a couple of issues they
need to consider when they're when
they're looking at this
whichever direction they're going in
ultimately a first of all this is a
conservation area
so you are mindful that development
needs to preserve or enhance
the character of the conservation area
that aside
the other point here is does this cause
harm to a designated
asset the designated asset is the
conservation area and this any list of
buildings that may be considered
nearby as well so you've got two stages
to that
one does it cause harm and you perhaps
need to consider in your own minds
whether it does or doesn't
cause harm if you reside that it does
cause harm essentially in terms of the
current regulations and laws and so on
we have
two categories of that which is less
social harm
or significant harm if you are
going down significant harm that's a
whole different ballgame but in terms of
less than substantial harm which i think
is where we're
sitting around here potentially you can
then consider
public benefits that outweigh or may
outweigh
that harm my only caveat to that
is a house for a family member
or young family might be considered me
more of a private benefit rather than a
public
benefit i will leave it there if i may
interesting um
councillor norris i thank you yes um
i took mr pope and g's comments on board
however
i actually don't myself either have a
serious issue with
what is proposed here i find the plan
very misleading the size of the cars in
relation to the proposed building
and yes maybe you could get two
two-bedroom
properties on this site uh with a bit of
a squeeze
but you would probably increase the
traffic movement on that basis
so without repeating many of the points
have already been made
i'm i'm inclined to go against the
recommendation
for uh refusal thank you
thank you any further comments yes
councillor mellon
thank you chair um yeah i'm
grateful to um the era planning manager
for his clarification there
um i find myself in two minds about this
one um
yes there is a lot of backland
development and and
the linear nature of the of the street
there
is just for a short period so i can see
that this would fit within the general
pattern of the
of the development in that area in the
village
um but i don't see the public benefits
that would outweigh any harm
um so it's a bit of a struggle the the
the plan
and the and the dimensions is quite
confusing
it seems to me that we'll end up with
something far more cramped on the site
than
than what appears on that uh
on that plan on page 273 um
and then there's the concern then about
some
maneuvering vehicles and that sort of
thing um
so yeah i i'm really quite torn about
this one
uh i'm not sure i can support it thank
you
thank you for that counselor melon
counselor humphreys thank you a little
bit of a question
to come back on there mr potentially
what what does
a low level of less than substantial
harm actually meaning layman's terms
that really helped
sorry to put you on no no
there is a degree of judgment in this
isn't there that's the point
um i'm hoping i wish i had a heritage
officer to come along
um ultimately the point of what is
deemed to be low level
is a subjective judgment um
any harm is going to be less than
substantial
it doesn't matter if it's medium low
high in this case i think they've
qualified it in terms of low of if you
took a scale within less than
substantial harm
you've got low medium high they're
saying it's low
in in that context at the point where it
turns over to be
significant harm on an asset
it's there is a sense of judgment i
suppose if you are saying
demolition of a listed building you
could argue that's significant
and we're we're moving into that
category but less than substantial harm
is
is the experience of the asset how it
affects
the character of that environment or the
setting of the listed building
um is it intrusive to that setting and
then there's
an extent of how intrusive is something
you know is it very little intrusion or
is it
high intrusion i can't answer that
question very easily
other than it is a subject of judgment
as we have to deal with every day
and did i see another handout was it yes
thank you chair uh
i would have sometimes the
public benefit uh with some of this is
is sometimes
masked and difficult to find
but with any of it there could be public
benefit depending on
how something is either conditioned or
or how we seem
deemed to approve it would it be
appropriate if if a public benefit
of someone being able to as it were
self-build and remain in their community
uh be deemed a public benefit certainly
is a public benefit within the
neighborhood plan because it says
opportunities for people to remain in
that community
should be at the forefront of some of
our housing policy
would it then be appropriate if this
were approved to make this personal to
the applicant
and of course if it then becomes a self
build we get in that naughty
territory of it they're not paying a
seal
so the public benefit is then somewhat
reduced
so you are hung in that balance and this
is where
self-building myself in the past i think
that self-builders not paying any
element of seal i think is a
really bad idea we can't change that
policy here today
uh but but it is somewhat reduced so
there is a public benefit in the wider
benefit of
someone potentially being able to
fulfill their own housing requirements
in the community that that they live in
currently
whether we whether we're able to
condition that to bring about that
public benefit
i'll i will defer to officers thank you
chair
thank you any further comments before i
pass a comment yes
counselor casted um yeah following on
from that i think um
i think there's a huge amount of benefit
in having a um
house of this size in um in this village
the um my first house that i the only
one that i could afford
when i was in my early 30s in my village
was smaller than this it had less land
around it
but it was it meant that i was able to
stay in the village where i was
i grew up and stay there so that's a big
benefit the other thing about this is
these outbuildings
um they've got tiled roofs they're
they're proper buildings they're
properly um developed buildings
and you could draw a line from the
corner of that top
out building on there down to that
bottom one and um
this development would be completely
contained
within that line the um
it would almost be contained if you went
to the larger outbuilding beside it
so um i don't think that there's a huge
amount of harm
caused by this if any harm i don't think
it affects the setting i don't think it
affects any visual amenity on it and i
think it's
a um a building that's in keeping with
ones around it that you could draw a
straight line down
and it would um it would fill in in
between the two
thank you right
um
ultimately um public benefit so public
benefit has been a debate at many appeal
um one of the more probably famous ones
is at woolpit in fact
and public benefit can be held to be a
whole host of different things
ultimately this is not providing
affordable housing so that's
not a public benefit we can consider but
it is providing a
house that house comes with employment
in terms of its construction
that house also comes with after
construction which is a temporary gain
uh an occupier who will be then
contributing
to the local facilities and shops and so
forth so there is a
possible benefit in economic terms
there but so you you have perhaps
that way forward i will say though that
this is not
a self-built house that is proposed as
such
it might be but it's not proposed as
such
um and uh we don't know about the
occupier being a local member or not
they obviously they've said they will be
but we are not
in planning terms we're not conditioning
or holding to that
and we don't really have a policy
needing to we are in the middle of a
settlement boundary
uh of this particular uh area so
i don't know if it helps really at all
the debate but again i just emphasize if
you are looking at
whether there's harm or not be very
clear in the sequence that we should
follow
going forward you for that well i've
been going
left and right right and left and back
again
um i i was interested to hear councillor
mellon's
view because i was listening to
everybody else and thinking yeah
actually yes because when i first looked
at this the officer has to take on board
what
she's been told and unfortunately i
think it was unfortunate that the
heritage officer wasn't here that we
could sort of
uh ask him further questions and now
john has
just sort of said uh
it may not be a self-filled house the
occupier is local
um and what is the public benefit um
it it it is really quite a difficult one
if members are minded that they do want
to approve it i think we should withdraw
pd rights definitely um
because um it is a very small site and
it is quite a large property
um i would ask the voids in the
uh upstairs can they be turned into
additional bedrooms
i don't know um
we have to ignore what whatever
personal things are attached to it this
is about planning
our planning officer has made a judgment
on it
and that's what before us that we have
to make a decision on
so i'm between a rock and a hard place
if anybody wants to propose anything um
yes sean
could i just um add something else to
the debate which
has followed some questions that have
been raised about sustainability oh
sorry
keep forgetting this um the there are
solar panels or a solar panel shown
on the roof um but we've not had an
indication of any of the other measures
which the agent did allude to in his
presentation
so if members are minded to approve
then we could put a condition on
requesting
further details of the sustainability
measures
and would solar panels be approved in a
conservation area
they they can be pd in a conservation
area
sorry they can be they're they are pd in
a conservation area
and i've just never said i think you
ought to withdraw competitive
development right meaning
you can't start building all sorts of
bits we can withdraw permitted
development rights for
extensions garaging
additional wars and fencing out
buildings we can withdraw those but that
would still be an appropriate um we can
do that yeah
okay right well there you are
members of the committee back to you
again
madam chair if i may just endorse what
the offer planning officers have said if
if there is going to be if there is
going to be a proposal to approve
contracts the officer's recommendation i
don't
for all i know there might not be but if
there is i think
your officer's advice is that the the
proposer and second should say
whether they think there is harm there's
a the advice of
professional advice is there is but you
don't fold that and if there is
why you think it's overcome by public
benefits
[Music]
we have a recommendation on page 241
does anyone want to make any comments
or proposals cancel a stream yeah
just just trying to sort of break the
damn wall if again
[Music]
we're often confronted here with things
that are bog standard and boring
and this isn't it this is something
that's been
yeah i would argue very well designed
and it follows something that we should
possibly encourage
i'm minded that looking at the hectares
i
often go back to the old ppg-3 document
which used to say about
you you normally use that as to whether
something's tight or not
this is at the lower end of what was
ppg3 25
dwellings per hectare because it used to
be between 25 30 and 50 i seem to
remember
but of course this building is big
enough to be two houses
so it is probably tight because it
if you could physically get two
dwellings in here you're pushing at the
higher having said that it's only it's
only 120.
if we're looking at what the public
benefit is
i always very skeptical of when appeal
inspectors say that well
during the build the bills will be
buying sandwiches at local shop
and doing this kind of stuff and so
therefore there'll be some short-term
public benefit this one is almost the
one where
if it were paying sill its contribution
to seal
i think it would demonstrate that public
benefit
and almost without it you would say it
wouldn't
so i asked the officers is there any way
that we can condition
that this building if it was if it
paid its way in seal could be
conditioned as it does that because i
personally in my own mind
if it had that wider public benefit of
washing its face in terms of its
community contribution
i would be prepared to support it i
think
just before john answers that i think we
had that
some considerable time ago because
unfortunately i've been doing this a
long time like you and
a council of stringer um and there were
cases where that was put on individual
properties
and people just said no we're not going
to do it and then of course times have
changed and moved on and still comes
into it
there is one other thing that we must
sort of think of here
is that if we do go minded with the
officer's recommendation
the applicant has the opportunity to
appeal
and i agree that they can appeal and we
can go back to bog standard and boring
yeah but it would it yeah it would go
through official channels
john you asked john for a response and i
i
i don't want to keep going around in
circles but it's a very good question
john
bear with me um
[Music]
in in terms of the question sorry the
the question of
can we attach sill to it
i think the answer is no um ultimately
because still
a community infrastructure levy is a
separate regime to planning
it's it's material to planning but it's
a separate mechanism um
which has its own regulations and
we're trying to sort of cross here in
terms of
um doing that and i think i would i
haven't got it to hand
but i would probably find quite a lot of
stuff telling me legally i'm not allowed
to do that if i went away and looked at
it but i'd have to go and look at it
i think ian's confirming
my instinct is that you're right mr
payton i think
what we can say is it's not it's not
been ident it's not an affordable house
dwelling and it's not been identified by
the applicant
as a self-built property has it as if it
was they would
hey there'd be the sill exemption and
there would be additional factors to
advise members on in terms of the
the policy encouragement of self build
that we have to take note of
um but i'm just trying to think off the
top of my head it might be technically
possible that it will become a self
build if it
if the owner landowner decides to do
things that way
that's the other thing of course would
self build is you can declare a property
that's been granted permission to be
self-built um
a year later you know and do it that way
and then because of the second
separate nature of seal regulations they
then when they put their sill
um form through they declare it as
self-build and they can avoid it'll be
zero still i don't know the technical
words but that's essentially
how that works so the answer is no i
can't find a way forward on that
i think ultimately if members are
looking at public benefits
we do have a construction benefit we do
have the it's not just
the builders on site going to the pub
and sandwich bars but we also have the
construction industry as a whole um
as a benefit you have other benefits
then in terms of the ongoing
operational nature of a dwelling and its
association with
the social and um economic
uses of the village going forward
those are our benefits
there isn't any real heritage benefits i
would suggest here that could be deemed
to be public benefits
for example restoring a list of building
or or so on
but you know what weight you give the
benefits that there are
is your discretion i think john we've
had quite a few refusals
even that appeals on some things such as
this with more
teeth to it so there's a difficult one
but i think we've sort of debated this
long and hard and i think something
needs to be done that we ought to make
some sort of proposal one way or the
other
council of war boys can i just
clarify so it's not just the impact on
the
um conservation area when you look at
the recommendation which the second part
as well
we're looking at restricted space for
the parking of maneuvering
of vehicles and i keep looking at the
plans on page two seven
two two seven three the width from the
um that's been put in the width from the
barn to the boundary
is 5.8 meters which is
just over the length of a large car
and there's two vehicle two bedrooms two
vehicles
whether i in when i've seen
similar properties built out or
it's actually been the the casa to the
problem
where how likely it is that cars going
up that drive will be actually backing
out into the street
or reversing into the property from the
street which
would wouldn't wouldn't really be
acceptable i think in terms of
the normal traffic on the street
um so that that is that is another
concern
it's a very finely weighted thing
that for me that because i think there
are attractions in the design of the
house and
and um it's
it's providing a home for for people in
in the village but that there is
i think a concern there that there is it
is too cramped to
sight and it would be insufficient to
allow
turning easily
well shall we just make some sort of
decision as to what thank you for your
comments i beg your pardon
thank you for your comments very very
useful comments too
so if we can make some sort of decision
and then we can vote one way or the
other council
before i make a proposal i just want to
a point of clarification on council of
war boys
it is not 5.8 meters between the house
and that bench it's 11.3
someone someone scaled it up half the
size when they drew that plan
okay so that measurement to the right is
11.3 not 5.8
right but the the measurement coming up
the driving where the cars are is
yes yes is what that's the war boys
as well thank you andrew right
uh hang on a minute john i think we're i
think we're sorry
if the officer wants to speak uh is this
relevant i'm just having i've just had a
thought but i would like can i have five
minutes with
a legal officer and the case officer
please yes
i think yes if that sounds a good idea
do i come
you can come do excuses can you suspend
the meeting for a moment
[Music]
right there's been legal and
[Music]
planning uh discussions which i will ask
john pateman g to help us with the very
difficult decisions that we've been
making today
or trying to thank you so
the reason i asked to have a word with
our legal colleagues
is a matter that has been progressing
through the debate
um there is a considerable confusion
about the dimensions and proportions and
the plans in front of us
i am concerned at the possible risk that
any decision whether
approval or refusal made given that
uncertainty
could be challenged and ultimately uh is
a
direct bearing on how you are judging
the impact of the building
and its association of land on the
conservation area
so it's for that reason i am going to
respectfully ask if the chairman may
propose
deferral for us to go back to the agent
go over all the plans and details so we
can
ensure that a clear concise and
correct set of plans are presented for
members to consider
me and so from the chair on that basis
i propose that we do defer the matter so
that we get accurate information of the
measurements which all of you were
clearly
um enquiring over
um and indeed um i did just catch
councillor humphrey's hand go
up um and do you i'd like to second that
to second it that we defer it
and what can we have the exact wording
for the reason for deferral please
so that we know what we're voting for
[Music]
so i would suggest we say we are looking
for clarification and confirmation
of all plan details in order to assess
the impact on the conservation area
okay sorry john just could you just
repeat the confirmation of all plan
details
uh in order to um
in order to assess the detail at the
impact on the conservation area
what inaccurate measurements did you
have in our missed that measure
yeah measurements
so i have the the application be
deferred for clarification and
confirmation of all plan details is that
including measurements
yes including measurements including
measurements to assess the impact on the
conservation area
yep in order to assess the impact on the
conservation area is that acceptable
chair mr peppermint
that sounds very acceptable so long as
um we've covered the issues that we were
all struggling with
chair if you're happy for me to proceed
i will yeah open the vote
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov app and go to the plus sign
in the top right hand corner of their
agendas
and there they will have the subsection
on attendance and voting and the vote
will be shown in progress in a light
blue colour council humphreys can i
please take your vote
thank you for
how's the carson are you is it you're
working or do you want me to take it
verbally
it's um it's taking a while to get in so
could i do it verbally absolutely
counselor
and that's for deferral oh thank you
councillor carsten
councillor norris could i just check are
you having any issues or has it gone
through
uh four deferrals
thank you councillors
so with that chair um
that's all votes now received so that
would be
six votes for deferral and one against
so the motion is motion for deferral is
carried thank you
um and do we have any site inspections
none to report chair in that case then
i'll now formally close the meeting and
thank you very much for everybody's
very informative debate thank you
thank you
you